Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is the world's only rabbi
with a black belt in jujitsu.
Rabbi Dr. Mordecai Finley.
Rabbi Finley holds a Doctorate in Religion and Social Ethics
from the University of Southern California.
He's the rabbi and co-founder of Ohr HaTorah Synagogue
in Los Angeles.
He's taught at USC, USC School of Law and Loyola Law School.
And he helped found and he's a former President
of the Academy for Jewish Religion.
He's here today for what I think is a pretty extraordinary
deep dive into timeless wisdom, mysticism, moral philosophy,
spiritual psychology, stoicism, higher consciousness,
and what it means to pursue a life of truth, of virtue,
wisdom, depth, purpose, and meaning beyond the material.
He's a beautiful man.
So hit that subscribe button and let's dig in.
This is me and Rabbi Mordecai Finley.
So nice to meet you. Thank you for doing this.
I appreciate you coming out here.
It's a real pleasure and honor to meet you
and being on your podcast.
I appreciate that.
Well, we were introduced by our mutual friend,
Steve Pressfield, any friend of Steve is a friend of mine.
Mutual (Mordecai laughing)
He speaks very highly of you.
And, you know, I've been doing this podcast thing
for about 8 1/2 years at this point.
And over the years I've had many spiritual teacher,
spiritual seeker and all types and forms,
but I have yet to sit down with a rabbi.
Here you go.
So, I'm Very excited
to talk to you today.
We were chatting a little bit before the podcast started
about our mutual adoration for Steve
and his focus on resistance.
And you were commenting.
I thought it'd be cool to kind of kick things off
with your sort of rabbi take on what that means
and how you interpret that.
The Hebrew term that matches under resistance in Hebrew
is called the (speaking in foreign language)
Hmm.
So the Hebrew word (foreign language)
is from the word to shape or form,
and (foreign language) means bad or evil.
So it says in the book of Genesis 6:5,
"when God is, as it were looking at creation
and those of the human being,
that all the thoughts of his inner life are all bad,
all day long."
Okay. It's a pretty dour,
understanding of the human condition.
The divine is very disappointed,
but in there it says, (speaking in foreign language)
All the shapes of the thoughts of his heart are all bad.
So from that we get the term (speaking in foreign language)
destructive shape.
So here's the idea, that whatever's going on inside of you,
however noble your vision, whatever it is you want to do,
there's a spoiler.
That sometimes the more you want to do something,
they (speaking in foreign language) actually opposes you.
Is not your friend.
So is somewhat connected to the (foreign language)
idea of the shadow, but it's very active in the unconscious.
So this idea is, it's just not well known in psychology.
There's all kinds of ways they talk around the idea
that there is an active intelligence in the inner life
that is oppositional.
Is that the same thing that you also call
The Inner Pharaoh?
Yes. One can call The Inner Pharaoh.
So in the Jewish calendar,
depending on what holiday we're working on,
we use the terminology for the holiday
to discuss spiritual psychology.
So The Inner Pharaoh is an archetype for Passover time,
but for the high holidays,
we'd probably use a different metaphor.
Or for example, (speaking in foreign language)
When we talk about penitence and self-examination
and confession, the resistance would be named differently.
But I would say throughout Jewish spiritual psychology,
including the spiritual psychology of the calendar,
the (speaking in foreign language)
the destructive patterns is any central term.
And what is the path towards deconstructing
the (speaking in foreign language)
So just a little bit of a background.
The Hebrew word, heart or lev,
lev does not mean what it means in English.
So in English, we think of the heart
as the seat of moral sentiments,
but the Bible you probably know says,
"do not follow after your heart or after your eyes,
which you go astray."
So people say, "Rabbi, shouldn't I follow my heart?"
I sacked the Bible says don't follow your heart.
And what does that mean?
I said, because the word heart is something different.
So, the word lev,
which means heart in modern Hebrew as well.
And I think it has that English connotation
of follow your heart.
But the Bible sees the heart as something like,
the mind feeling continuum, that's not connected
to the spirit, to the soul, to a vision.
So in a sense, it's a lens of prison,
through which the world is understood
and then directs us according to his own needs.
So, I might, for example,
lets say in my conscious self connected to my vision,
I might want one thing,
but my lev, right, wants something else.
Right?
It doesn't want difficult things.
It wants the easier path.
For some people wants to depress,
another person, it wants to dominate,
another person who wants to be right
and the person feels guilt.
So, think of the inner life as having patterns.
So the first step is to realize that,
let's say in the beginning state,
we don't know that there is an inner world,
I call the ego self, that's actually driving us.
We think our will is driving us,
but the ego self is driving us.
So then, if one wants to really do this work,
you have to go to something called the higher self,
and examine the ego self.
So that's the main thing.
Right?
You have to know what's happening in your ego self.
Well, it presupposes
that there is this duality, right?
That there is indeed something called the higher self
and then understanding what that is becomes,
a tricky process, right?
My sense is that most people lack the ability
to truly live an examined life and are predominantly living,
you know, as an expression of the ego for the most part.
And despite all the work that I've done,
I'm probably driving my life on self well, most of the time,
and it's a constant reminder like this refrain
to come back to this idea of trying to connect
with the higher self,
and discern the truth of that in juxtaposition
with, you know, my ego-driven will.
So, untangling that, you know, sticky wicket
is something I suspect that in your counseling,
you spend a lot of time trying to get people to understand.
Yes.
And that's one way I think Steven Pressfield
and I connected.
Was because when he had already written "The War of Art,"
and then you heard about,
that I'm teaching something very similar.
So he came to study with me in my classes that I teach,
and he saw that I have a very rigorous,
detailed understanding of the inner life,
what exactly the higher self is,
what exactly the ego self is,
the distinction between the colloquial use of the word ego,
and ego self, 'cause they're actually quite different.
And he really admired the precision and then we just,
we met and talked about it constantly.
And I learned a lot from him clearly
'cause he's really suffered.
He's really paid the dues of working through resistance.
And I think he liked the idea that there is a concept
that exists that I've developed.
And so, our connection developed over that.
Right?
So it is very important I find,
and this is where I have to say to people,
I'm gonna have to teach criminology.
I'm gonna have to teach you a map.
Because I believe that if one understands the map
and understands how to use language precisely,
it actually helps in the journey.
So what are those terms that have to initially
be concretely defined?
First of all the ego self.
Now, here's where the term ego,
put the Freudian sounds out completely
because it is not helpful.
But let's say when people say my ego got in my way.
That has a sense of narcissism, domination, what I want,
but many people suffer from guilt and shame.
So they don't seem ego-driven people,
they seem like very nice people.
So the flaw in their ego self is not narcissism,
but self-loathing, self-doubt.
So it was very hard to call that my ego got in my way.
There is a narcissistic take flare to that in that,
you're still the protagonist in this grand play, right?
Things tend to revolve around you,
even if it's about self-pity and self-doubt.
Yeah, so that's really at a higher level
understanding of ego.
But most people when they say my ego got in my way,
they don't say, my ego narrative that is my narcissistic
drama that I'm always at fault.
That's a level of sophistication that, I mean, you have it,
but many people don't.
So that's why when I say, I mean ego self,
because when I look at what I call the 20 or so disruptions
of the ego self, anger at others, anger at the self,
resentment, despair, shame, guilt, envy,
confusion, low-level desire,
I mean, the whole range of them.
So these are all in the ego self.
So when a person starts out on this work,
they have to find that way to the higher self
so they can actually watch the ego self.
And so how do you tease that out of somebody?
Okay.
So, the steps of the higher self start with what I call
the observer mind, which most people do
but they don't do it in a rigorous proactive way.
So I'll introduce somebody to recounting for me a moment
when, what I call a disruption of their ego self
took over their consciousness.
And I gotta find out what their deal is.
Whether it was anger, resentment, despair, confusion,
guilt, shame, whatever it is.
And I say, I want you to try to see it, but not be it.
I want you to, as it were, have some distance
and you can see that it is happening to you,
but it is not the same as you.
And for some people they can do that pretty quickly.
That they can disidentify from it.
So the process of disidentifying it,
so you can see it and name it.
There are little quips here.
You can identify it if you can disidentify from it.
If you can name it, you can tame it.
If you can see it, you don't have to be it.
So there's a series of ways that I teach it,
but the moment is when a person says,
I can see the anger without being angry, but I can see it.
That takes work in and of itself though.
A lot of work.
Right?
For most people,
the minute you confront somebody with the truth
of their lower emotional state,
the impulse is to become defensive, right?
Absolutely.
So, protectionism kind of reaction to that kind of thing.
And, you know, as we were also chatting
about before the podcast,
like I come from from a 12 step tradition,
long time recovery guy,
and in a very different, you know,
with a sort of analogous, but different set of tools,
that whole journey and process is about,
getting you to objectively confront with the, you know,
the factual state of your big, you know,
character defects and behavioral reality.
That's exactly right.
Which is, we also said before the podcast that,
two of the many influences in my life,
one of them is really 12 steps.
I've been, you know,
I'm not officially in a 12 step program,
but I've been 12 step world adjacent
for almost my entire professional life.
I was the informal chaplain of a Jewish 12 step group
back in the 80s.
Oh, wow.
And they've always stayed connected.
I'll tell you more about that one
'cause it was a life-changing moment.
Wow.
First time I went to a 12 step meeting.
But any case, the idea of being able to see what's happening
in your ego self from the observer mind
is the beginning of the journey.
And so, the people that work with me, I say,
you have to do this every day.
Every single day, you have to do the practice
of the disidentification from the ego self,
observe what's happening,
and then there are several next steps that I would teach
for the what I'll call the beginner to intermediate.
Now, why is that?
Because at some level I want to teach people virtue,
which is the ability to observe the ego self
and not do whatever it says,
but rather act in ways that according
to your vision of yourself, which requires a virtue code.
Rationality, to try to understand the inner life
of the ego self.
Because every disruption has an inner life,
every disruption has a story.
So anger has a story, depression has a story.
So person has to be able to rash,
just like understanding another person.
You have to rationally understand what's happening
in your ego self.
So I call it the virtue, rationality,
and then wisdom you might say is,
developing a sense of how to manage this whole thing.
So we think of a wise person,
they can regulate their ego selves,
they live lives of virtue,
but they have to have a sense
of where that all this is heading.
The larger picture of a life of goodness.
And beyond that is depth.
Now, many people aren't that interested in depth,
meaning the world of the soul.
So if they can get virtue, rationality and wisdom down,
they're good to go.
Right.
No need to go further.
But there are many people
that just have an innate aching for depth.
And it's not well taught it in this country.
So, I saved that for people who, if they've gotten past,
I mean, if they have relative mastery of virtual,
rationality and wisdom, then we can go to depth.
Mm-hmm, one step at a time though.
Yeah, I really think it's one step at a time.
'Cause there are many people have to go to depth,
but they can't manage their emotions.
Yeah.
They can't manage their connection with their spouses
or kids or parents, so.
Because we're emotional beings.
And when we talk about being able to objectively assess,
you know, the true status of how you're behaving,
it involves decoupling all of those narratives and stories
that we attach to our experiences and things
that we've done or, you know,
kind of experienced throughout our lives.
And, you know, we feel, I feel like human beings
are predisposed to, you know, make sense of the world
by storytelling.
And so when something happens to us, we're like,
this is why it happened, and then we, you know,
attach disproportionately, you know,
emotional story to that and that becomes our truth, right?
That the emotions that surround that become real,
whether or not they're tethered to, you know,
factual reality-
Yeah,
and people say that's my truth.
And in spiritual psychology, you should say, that's my lie.
Right (Rich laughing)
Right?
Uh-huh. And what happens
when you confront people with that?
Oh, when you basically realized that your ego self
produces mendacious narratives, I mean,
that's actually quite relieving.
That's what the ego self does.
It creates narratives that justifies your thoughts,
feelings, and emotions, that's his job.
So it's the job of a truly sentient wise human being,
don't buy into it.
Right.
But it requires challenging your whole sense of self.
Like it's an attack on identity on some level.
So, I would suspect that over the years,
you've developed a gracious set of tools
for meeting people where they're at and very gently
teasing these things out of them until they can lead
with a sense of curiosity rather than-
Yeah, it is curiosity.
When you move to the observer mind, no judgment,
just observe what's happening.
But there is a definition of self,
because when people identify their ego self, thoughts,
feelings, and emotions as the self, I say, you know,
there is such a larger self that you're gonna discover,
and you wanna get out of that prison.
Because you're observing the world through prison bars.
And if you think that's all there is,
you're gonna stay in that cell.
But if you are willing to accept the fact that,
there's actually a world,
this is not dissimilar to Plato's allegory of the cave.
If you actually wanna break the shackles
and break out of those prison bars, there's a way.
I say, and the main way you know
you're living in that prison is suffering.
Right?
If you're suffering or you're causing other people
to suffer unnecessarily,
there's an indication that your identification of self
is insufficient.
But there's a competing idea that that suffering
is serving that individual in some way, right?
Like the attachment to that suffering
is playing a role in how this person navigates
throughout the world.
And when you come to them and say,
you got to let go of this,
and there's a whole larger world available to you,
it's terrifying, right?
So unless somebody is in sufficient amount of pain,
getting them to transition out of that is an uphill battle.
It really is.
So oftentimes when a person comes to me and I have several,
I call this wisdom counseling.
I have several methods depending on the person.
But let's say a person comes to me and says,
" Hey, Rabbi, what's this all about?
Give me the big picture before I sign up."
So I'll say, all right,
I want you to give me a theory of the good in your life,
every part of your life, your romantic connections,
children, work, and a relatively precise,
as detailed as possible, what you would like,
what you would think, what would you feel,
what you would say, how others would react to you
as precise as possible.
I call this a relatively precise vision for your life.
If you could live optimally, what would it be like?
So it's not that I say, you have to,
I want them to say, "I have to."
I say, I'm not telling you do anything.
But if you have a relatively detailed vision
that you know yourself would lead to a flourishing life,
the Greek idea of eudaimonia, then the question is,
what's the gap?
And how do we close the gap?
And if you wanna close the gap, I'll help you.
What is the percentage of people that come to you who,
hold that vision for themselves versus the individual
who comes in and says, "Look on paper, everything's good.
I got a good job, drive a nice car, I've got a nice family,
sometimes my kids hate me, but I can pay the mortgage
and I go to this job, it's fine,
but there's something missing in my life.
I don't know what it is, but I feel this sense of calling
to something greater, but I have no connection
to what that might be yet."
It's not an uncommon question to that yet.
So then I have to say, like, are you signing up?
It's like my jujitsu club.
Are you signing up?
Because is this a one-off-
Flirtation?
Yeah, if it's a one-off, that's fine.
I'll give you a couple of ideas.
But if you're signing up,
which means you might come to my wisdom classes
on Wednesday nights, come to one thing or another,
then I would start with, can we break this down?
So, you're not get along with your kids,
I need to know more about that,
because sometimes people suffer,
because they're not nourished
by their interpersonal relationships.
And let's say, for example,
their stringent with their child is killing them.
Or I have a nice job,
but at some level they hate the job
and they're done with it.
So, when a person says, "I'm basically doing okay,
but something's missing."
The first thing I have to do is,
find out exactly what's happening in each of these areas,
and see if something's missing in there.
Typically something is.
Typically, they don't know how to process with the spouse.
They don't know how to process with the kids.
Their work life has, you know,
reached its maximum potential for meaning.
So, once we start examining things,
the sense of something's missing,
let's get to what exactly is missing.
Now let's say a person hardly ever, but a person reports,
"Relationships are good, I'm rarely regulated,
we're processing."
And I hear all that and I say, okay, so it's depth.
If you feel something missing, if you feel the abyss within,
we call that depth, and that takes hard work.
And then what is the process going forward
of getting somebody more connected to that?
Oh, to depth.
Yeah.
So we're jumping to the end though, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're talking like-
I'm going to AP course.
Okay, man.
So we're going right to the brown belt black belt level.
Most people are happy with the blue belt, okay?
So if I got that person who says,
"I'm not stopping until I get my higher belt."
So I use the approach of Jung, Carl Jung.
Not any kind of doctrinaire sense,
but ultimately in the realm of the soul,
it's a meaning driven part of the inner life.
It can be addressed through religion, philosophy, art.
I think religion, philosophy and art come out of the soul,
and I think the soul is the aspect of the human being
that actually apprehends symbols, myths, poetry,
music at the deep level.
So, we'll call the soul effect,
minimally a faculty of knowing.
James Hillman's one of my favorite people to study here.
He says, "The soul is where events become experiences,
where things are taken down."
So first of all, the soul is always at work,
but sometimes undernourished, unexpressed,
and from Jung's perspective, that's why you suffer.
You suffer because you haven't found a way
to let the concerns of the soul manifest into your life.
So unlike Freud, where he, you know,
Freud thought it was because of repression,
Jung thought it was more, the inability for a person
to articulate the concerns of the soul into their lives.
And then just come some time for investigation.
Mm-hmm.
I gotta find out what medium they connect to immediately.
Music, movies, books, poetry, you know,
now and then I get a person where the marriage is in trouble
because the wife says,
"I can't be married to a superficial man."
So, "You know, we've done it for 30 years and now I'm done."
Right.
She spent her weekends in Sedona.
He says, "I don't know what she's talking about."
So it's an external pressure.
Yes.
And he said, "what is this thing?"
And, you know, accountant, lawyer (laughing)
And, you know, like," And my marriage is at stake.
What do I do rabbi?"
I said, okay.
So I tried to figure out like, where's the opening here.
So I find, he's a guy a little bit older than I am.
I'm 66 about 70, and music, rock music.
I said, okay.
I said, "are you aware that the Beatles changed
from 62 to 66?"
You know, that happened, right?
Mm-hmm.
So yes.
I want you to go back and listen to the Beatles after 65,
Abbey Road, Rubber Soul,
I want you to tell me what happened.
Okay?
So, he called me and said,
"Okay, I found a better therapist."
I said it's okay.
(both laughing)
That's hilarious.
I know, huh?
But-
He got scared.
Because, listen to Abbey Road, what's happening there,
listen to Rubber Soul, listen to Revolver.
Right.
You know, listen, what happened to this guy?
Or Sergeant pepper.
Sergeant pepper.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And then I said, and tell me what happened to them.
So I think he wanted to talk about his mother.
Yeah.
He was like,
how do you feel-
Right, right, right.
Yeah. So-
Yeah, I'd say,
it was a spiritual awakening that they had,
they went on a journey and they became more expanded
individuals and in turn, more fully expressed artists.
That's scary.
Right?
Yeah. The Beatles, yes.
Yeah.
And the thing is, I have a lot of compassion
for that guy who comes to you,
I think that's the predicament of the typical modern human,
because we live in a time that I would define as a crisis
of consciousness and spiritual connection, right?
We're in this sort of competitive predatory relationship
with other people, with ourselves, with the world,
it's a zero sum approach to basically everything
where material is seeking answers in ego status, money,
power, consumption, accumulation,
and it's also a culture in which it's considered,
a lower order naivete to seek reconciliation
or answers in the mystical and the unknown, right?
It's almost perceived as a weakness in this age of science.
And yet when you look around,
you see depression rates and suicide rates
at unprecedented levels,
we're seeing this breakdown in our ability
to civilly communicate with each other,
the seeds of social destruction and have been sewn, right?
And from my perspective,
the only way for the only salvation is in spiritual practice
and learning to more deeply connect with who we are,
to find our innate humanity that allows us
to connect to others and live more symbiotically, you know,
on this planet that supports us.
And yet I despair at times
because I don't see that as a cultural priority.
First of all, beautifully articulated, really impressive.
You really nailed it.
And it's not often that I sit in conversation with somebody
who really articulates it as beautifully and concisely
as you have.
So, right on.
All right, thank you.
So the first thing I wanna say is,
one podcast at a time, you know, but at a deeper level,
well, that's my work.
So, you know, when I do my Torah teachings
on Saturday mornings on Zoom now, this is what I'm after.
I'm teaching it in order for people to master
virtue, rationality, wisdom and depth.
And I have to teach in such a way
where no matter what level they're at,
white belt to black belt,
I have something for everybody.
And I remember it was a few weeks ago, we got to this.
And you could almost feel the depth in the Zoom room.
And one person shared a statement from Kafka where he said,
"Language is like ice over a lake."
I'm sorry, something like,
"There's ice over the lake of the soul
and eight languages they ax.
And we have to break through the ice to get to the water."
And some great metaphor and, I mean,
it's like we're all in.
Everybody was saying,
"Well, Kate's and Wordsworth and William Blake."
I mean, all these quotes, just beginning to flow in,
and it's like we all went into the zone.
So I know is possible.
Yeah.
And for the people who weren't at that level,
they were listening in and say," well, how do I do this?
I want more, I want to live more deeply,
I want to live with a greater sense of my soul
and the souls of other people."
So, part of it is to let people know that it's there.
Yeah.
That you're connected to the mystery,
but the path is not that mysterious, it's actually a path.
I mean, there is an incremental conscious path
that one can take into the world of depth.
And so part of my work is to make the journey to mystery
apprehendable and the people can master it
according to their ability.
So, yeah, I agree.
And I consider that to be at the core of my life's work.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change."
Featuring excerpts from poignant essays by and glorious
photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast, it's a gorgeous artful compendium
of the show and copious wisdom shared there in.
All wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website,
signed copies are available,
and we are shipping globally direct to any coffee table
on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's richroll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
And your tools are the rabbinical traditions,
social psychology, mysticism, Kabbalah,
which I want to talk a little bit about,
but how do these all kind of congeal,
because my sense is that, you're...
I wouldn't consider you an iconoclast,
but you're different from the typical rabbi in that,
you're well steeped in military history,
you've got a black belt in jujitsu,
you were in the Marine Corps
and you have what I would consider to be, you know,
a pretty objective lens on the pitfalls
of religious traditions in general.
Sure.
Yeah.
Well, yeah, a lot of life experience
before I entertain there into becoming a rabbi.
And so when I went to college,
I began college at 22 years old after growing up
and being in the military.
You were in the Marine Corps for three-
Three years.
Yes, from eight...
I joined out of high school and I also had a,
kind of a rocky time growing up.
And I saw and experience things
I know had an indelible effect on me
that I had to deal with.
To just name it, I grew up in Compton as a white kid.
And although my buddies on my street were fabulous,
I mean, they fought for me.
I saw a hatred and savagery that a person shouldn't have
to see and experience when they're 12, 13, 14 years old.
It never made me hate,
but it made me confused about the human condition.
I didn't know how to talk about it when I was that age.
And so, I was in 9th grade, I was reading KEMU and SART.
It just something spring opened in me
that said I have to understand the human condition.
So my first flirtation with existentialism, you know,
we're thrown into an uncaring world
and we have to create meaning ourselves.
So that was a big part of my high school life and-
It's interesting that your on ramp really,
to the work that you do today was one
that's rooted in philosophy, not religious tradition.
So you didn't come up through, you know,
the sort of synagogue, indoctrination of how you-
I didn't take a series-
To what you do now.
Look, I went to Hebrew school, I went to confirmation,
you know-
Didn't connect with you than now?
It didn't connect me.
I was incredibly fortunate that I had a spiritual teacher
in high school.
Again, it's just a rare thing that my science teacher
was a spiritual man in the Gurdjieff tradition.
Have you ever heard of Gurdjieff?
Uh-uh.
Okay. So Gurdjieff was a great spiritual teacher
in the 20th century.
I mean, back in the 50s and 60s,
everybody knew who Gurdjieff was.
So he vetted me.
I tell you a quick story?
Yeah.
Yeah, okay. So I'm in science-
That's what we're here for.
Yeah, so I'm in my science class Lynwood high school.
And he would talk and, you know,
like the theory of spontaneous generation
when they did not understand where bacteria came from.
And he would say,
"Some people believe that things spontaneously generate,
but others know that everything generates
from a deeper reality."
And he looked right at me and then he'd move on.
I said, is he talking to me?
Right?
So he would do this, right.
He was just like, talk and then look at me
and like drill something in.
So I came after school one day and I said, okay,
is this real?
Are you actually stopping every now and then,
and then saying something to me at some really deep level?
He said, "okay, I was waiting for you to notice and to ask."
And I said, yes, I noticed that I'm asking.
He says, "do you want to study with me?"
I said, sure.
He says, "okay, every Wednesday afternoon
come to S 109, science class 109."
And I would go every afternoon
and he taught me about the soul and spirit and life
and expanded consciousness.
It wasn't on the curriculum,
but...And he was a rigorous teacher.
Yeah, that's wild.
It was wild.
Everybody needs somebody like that.
You know, I felt-
Too few get somebody like that.
How did you get somebody like that?
How do you, I mean, I just felt so incredibly fortunate
that he was there.
Because, you know, this is L.A.
and I was coming apart.
And he said,
"There's this great fellowship of human awareness,
and there's not that many people, but when you are one,
you can recognize others and this is the most real thing."
So, he says, "you got to take this seriously."
So I was his student.
And one thing I noticed was, I was having trouble
living up to it.
Because there was drugs and alcohol,
all these distractions and I realized,
if I'm true to this deepest thing that I know,
and I didn't get from my synagogue,
I got it from Jack Bishop.
And I told Jack, I gotta get outta here,
and I gotta go somewhere where,
they're gonna make me be this.
And that's why I joined the Marine Corps.
I joined the Marine Corps because, you know,
they shave your heads and you can't talk for three months.
I mean, I wanted the eradication of that ego
that I'd built up in high school, downed to nothing
and built up from there.
And that's what the Marines Corps-
And you had this self-awareness...
You had that level of self-awareness
about that at that time-
I'm sitting here thinking to myself when I was 17, 18,
I really can't believe those were my actual thoughts.
I need to eradicate myself and build from the core.
Mm-hmm.
And-
So go into this institution, allow them to break you down,
where you're confronted with yourself
in that very real way and rebuild yourself.
That's what-
Under that kind of,
that level of discipline and rigor.
Yeah. And it did it.
It was true.
It really did it.
And what I discovered was in that, let's say,
100 guys in a platoon, in a basic training platoon,
about 20 where these guys.
Really?
Wow.
There were so many spiritual seekers.
So that was what year?
Yeah, 73.
73.
1973.
Yeah, so my drill instructor was one of them.
You know, a person in the fellowship, I'll say,
for lack of a better term.
So he calls me in, you know,
so the way you get called in was,
they name a class of like football players
or whatever they needed.
So he says, "all Hebrew motherfucker,
report to the duty office."
So we're all looking around, okay, so, count on the door,
"sir, one Hebrew motherfucker reporting as ordered."
So, I go in and he looks at me and he looks at my file
and he sees I have a high IQ, looks he says,
"what are you doing here?"
So I said, "oh, fight for my country."
He goes, "what you're really doing here?"
So I just had to be honest as I need to transform.
I just kind of confessed.
And he says, "okay."
He says, "how many people in the Marine Corps
do you think were like you?"
I said one in 1000.
He said, one in 10,000.
So he says, "don't tell anybody about it,
keep your mouth shut."
He said, "I'll try to help you."
Wow. A little bit of a guardian angel.
Whoa. And-
Because he feared you'd get chewed up and spit out?
Yeah. So he, in a way, I mean,
he was a tough Marine Corps drill Sergeant,
but he had his eye out for me.
And it was crazy because, you know,
okay, so, one thing he did was,
he would play with our minds,
and he wanted to see who got it.
So, one time we're at the chow hall and he says, you know,
we're standing here he says,
"IPT physical trained are platoon to death.
And the ghosts are here as are their ghost rifles.
And I want everybody to pick up your ghost rifle
because you think just 'cause you're outside the chow hall,
you don't have to do close order drill?"
He says, "everybody gets their rifle.
Make sure you have the right rifle."
Like I was looking around, so, I and the 20 other guys
we all start picking up ghost rifles.
So then everybody says,
"okay, so we all pick up our ghost rifles."
He says, "does everybody have the correct rifle?"
I said, this private doesn't sir.
So he goes, "who in the fuck has private Finley's rifle?"
So somebody goes, "sir, this private,
would you please give it to ref?"
So, we're doing all this stuff and the other guys are going,
"what is happening here?"
So he would play mind games with us
the whole way through bootcamp, and I and a few others
got it.
Expand reality.
It's like my teacher in high school,
I went from the high school teacher
to the Marine Corps teacher.
And the whole thing was,
we're living in a world that you don't get, it's a mystery,
open your minds up.
So-
A flip side of that-
Yeah.
Experience would have been for you to,
rather than join the Marine Corps,
to go to India and do the Ram Dass thing, right?
That's what everybody else was doing.
Yeah, and sit at the feet of Neem Karoli Baba,
who essentially, you know,
your platoon leader is a stand in for that type of guru
student teacher, you know, dynamic.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, to be honest, I wanted the G.I. Bill,
(both laughing)
and we've not as a Patriot.
Uh-huh.
You know, Vietnam kind of destroyed our military.
Everybody kept saying, "oh, it's such a bad military."
So why don't you join to make it better?
So I was really the kind of guy that said,
hey, we want to rebuild this military,
is gonna be 1% at the time I'm going in and do my part.
So as a Patriot, but more than anything
was a spiritual search and the idea that I landed
from my high school teacher Bishop
into my Marine Corps platoon with Sergeant Throne Berry,
who was, yeah, he was a guru.
It was so unreal to me, Rich.
I mean, truly it was-
You look back, hindsight's always 2020,
and life always makes perfect sense in the rear view mirror,
there's this feeling of predestiny, right?
You're like, you're sort of being prepared
for this life that you live now,
my feeling is that, we all have chance encounters
with great teachers and it's incumbent upon us
to have the awareness to really see and understand
when we're having one of those encounters
so that we can value it and nurture it and appreciate it.
Yeah. I agree with you.
I didn't feel predestination as much as I was working
and doors opened because I was doing the work.
but the doors that opened with Bishop and Throneberry
for example, felt miraculous,
and they defined me as human beings.
So then when it came time for me to go to college,
I wanted to study religion because I wanted to get
at the truth of things.
So I did religion, anthropology, philosophy,
and I had a really good undergraduate degree.
I mean, I was really able to tailor,
make it to my spiritual search.
I read great books and studied with great people.
Was there an idea that you'd be a professor
or what was the sense of career path?
I had no goal other than discover the truth.
I didn't, actually I was a B student in high school.
I didn't know I'd be, so I was this straight A student
in college, I didn't even know I had the aptitude
to tell you the truth.
Yeah.
And then they said professor,
like, "oh, you're professorial."
And I studied religion, and I think I want to be a rabbi.
And my motivation was, I think rabbis sit around
and study ancient tomes.
Right.
I forgot they have congregations.
So, when I showed up at Rabbinical School
and I got my slip of paper, here's your congregation,
I said, what?
(both laughing)
You have to get up and talk in front of people.
I gotta go out there and preach.
I thought like, we just kind of steadied
ancient antiquarian books and knew God.
So, I was so naive,
it wasn't until they gave me my assignment
that I remembered, oh, congregational rabbi.
Right.
So.
And that's how it began.
Yeah. That's how it began.
Yeah.
So where, you know, where does the interest
in all these other kinds of strains of thought come in to,
you know, how you practice being a rabbi?
Well, so my religion degree unders...
We focused in the function of religion, not morphology, Jews
and Christianity, Islam, the comparative approach,
but what does religion do?
Organize reality?
So we understood, for example, Marxism is a quasi religion,
which you might call the,
what's happening in politics today.
Some of them are quasi religious because they're in a way
based on things that cannot be empirically shown,
but they believe to exist.
So they have something of a religious quality to them.
So we learned how religion functions.
I also took symbolic anthropology.
So the degree that I cobbled together for myself
was foundational how we understand the world.
Human consciousness, the nature of the symbolic life,
introduction to Carl Jung,
the whole history of philosophical hermeneutics,
how language functions, that connection between language
and consciousness.
I mean, I really had an extraordinary undergraduate degree.
Then I went to Rabbinical School for a couple of years,
and I realized, I don't know enough.
So I went back and did a doctorate
in Religion-Social Ethics,
so I could understand this thing better.
So, I'm one of those few people I think that my degrees,
both my undergraduate and PhD were in part of my search
for truth.
And I just lucked into the best program
with the best teachers who at some level,
let me do what I wanted.
And so I still am reaping benefits from my undergraduate
and doctoral program.
In rabbinical school I mostly learned how to read the text.
Meaning in rabbinical school, I learned how to do Talmud
and Midrash and read Aramaic to study the Zohar,
so that was a very good education
in accessing the mysteries of the tradition.
But the intellectual tools
I got from my two degrees from USC.
And I would say that trajectory is still moving forward.
I mean, it is.
Right, right.
And, and how has your...
Clearly, the way that you kind of do what you do
is a little bit askew from the typical rabbi.
How does the sort of Jewish community perceive you?
Like, are you considered... Like is it,
certainly there's different, you know, traditional strains
and Orthodox and all of that,
but are you like welcomed as an equal voice
in this conversation?
What I hear is I'm highly respected.
Yeah.
That's what I hear.
I'm a reform ordained rabbi,
but I'm not in the social justice thing.
And there's enough people trying to fix society,
fix other people I don't need involved in.
I wanna name it, the human soul.
So my colleagues know that I'm not the guy that you call
when you want a social justice warrior.
I'm the guy you call if you want access
to the mysteries of the inner life.
And so I'm not in step with what I'll call reform Judaism,
but I think there's a lot of other rabbis
and reformed Judaism who are interested in this very thing.
Very few of them got to start when they were 16, right?
And have been on it since they were 16.
So I think I have an important voice.
And also because I studied Aramaic,
which opened up the Zohar to me, so at a young age,
I mastered skills that have opened up texts that some rabbis
just can't get to because they didn't spend time
on the original languages.
But many are, I'm not alone in this.
There are other reform rabbis that are equally deep,
equally learned, have mastery of the languages,
and we end up in similar places.
Well, I would imagine being so well versed
and steeped in a variety of traditions and philosophies
and, you know, traditions around psychology,
that that would really make your perspective
on traditional Jewish philosophy and texts much more robust.
Yeah. Yes.
So, I tell people, I don't like theology, for example,
theology wants to take the mystery and put it into a box
with a nice bow.
So I'm more interested in symbols, myths, metaphors,
as mediating between the conscious and the unconscious mind.
So I have a specific way that I teach people how to read
a text as an entryway into the soul.
It just so happens that in the Hasidic tradition,
which branched off from the Kabbalah,
that's also their main way.
So, when I discovered a Hasidic tech that says,
"every word of the Bible and the prayer book
is an opening into a cavern filled with souls,
and worlds and angels," I shuttered.
Oh, so you've been there too?
Yeah. That's beautiful.
Isn't it?
So I discovered it by myself,
and then I found out it's actually, it's a theory
that's goes back to the late 1700s.
So when I discovered that the branch called Hasidic Judaism,
Hasidic doesn't mean the ultra Orthodox,
it's a specific kind of mythical teaching
that most of them happened to be ultra Orthodox.
But once I discovered those worlds and those texts,
man, that was, it's like I felt I discovered, you know,
my people.
Yeah.
So I still am deeply immersed in,
like last night I did a two hour,
'cause it's the Jewish holiday last night and today,
I did a two hour teaching on a couple of paragraphs
from a Hasidic texts from the 1870s.
And we just went deeper and deeper and deeper and, you know,
I got off and people were saying to me,
"put it online, and we have to study it,
and tell us what your sources were," and, you know,
so its a-
Yeah.
So extraordinary.
Well, I love the deep appreciation for the mystical,
and you know, when I think back to how we started this,
talking about Steve Pressfield and resistance,
one of the things that I really appreciate
about Stephen's work is that, it's very practical.
Like here's what you do.
If you're dealing with resistance,
here's a path towards, you know, overcoming it.
But within that, there's a whole universe of mysticism
because it's about courting the muse and showing up
for the work so that the muse can become present.
And, I just find that life is more colorful and beautiful
when we make room for things mystical.
And it allows me to connect with my own innate, you know,
with humility.
As beautifully put.
And I always remind people,
the reason I want to deal with the disruptions
of the ego self and deal with the resistance,
is to leave space, to live a life of wisdom.
You know, so virtue, rationality.
Now we can actually live with some wisdom.
We're not always putting out fires
that the ego self creates.
We're not always dealing with disruptions with other people.
Relationships aren't always getting into a car wreck.
Okay, now, now you're ready for the mystery.
In fact, I just said to the rehab guys on Friday,
I talked about that.
I said, sobriety prepares you for the mystery.
Sobriety is good at in and of itself.
But one thing that using does,
and again, this is a private theory,
doesn't apply to everybody,
the mystery so deep and painful
that people would rather drink and use drugs
than to feel the pain of the mystery.
And so, for some people sobriety is a way to say,
I'm now gonna go into the mystery and it's gonna be painful
to discover the beauty, that life is both beautiful
and ephemeral, which is unbearable sometimes.
Yeah.
But, do it any way.
And you're not gonna drink.
Yeah. Well, you were sharing before the podcast
about working with people in recovery
and how receptive they are to these ideas, right?
And I think my theory on that is that, maybe not all,
but a lot of addicts and alcoholics
are fundamentally seekers.
They're seeking answers, they're seeking a resolution
to their discomfort, they're doing it in an unhealthy way
and they're using substances as a portal
to an alternative reality, right?
It works until it doesn't work,
you're confronted with the truth of your behavior,
you've gotta find a new way forward,
but because you've had those experiences
of trying to fill that hole, that spiritual hole,
you're already predisposed to wanna be on that journey.
And I find that, once somebody has built a solid foundation
of sobriety, they're thirsty,
they're really hungry for that path.
100%.
And that's why for some people who once they gain sobriety
in 12 steps as part of their lives forever, I say,
And now go find, whatever you grew up in,
whatever you're comfortable with, to go on the spiritual
religious path, if it fits you.
But you just have to find the right church,
the right synagogue, the right mosque.
You have to find the one that's gonna speak to your soul.
So I say to people, 12 step is necessary,
but not sufficient for some people.
Mm-hmm. It is a spiritual program.
It is-
But how do you parse somebody
who's walking a spiritual path versus religion?
That's a great question.
And the distinction between spiritual and religious
is a tough one.
Religious sometimes means,
let's say from a Jewish perspective,
you officially accept the dogma.
Like, what do I got to believe?
You know, one God, whatever.
Was a buy-in.
Yeah. Just, I buy into the dollar.
Yeah.
Now, depending on your denomination,
you gotta buy into enough ritual.
You know, whatever your denomination is.
And then you show up and you have community,
and there's fellowship and as long as you stay
within, you know, those four cubits.
But oftentimes when you start asking questions
that no one else is asking,
and you're seeking deeper things,
at some point, you gotta either find a couple of people
in that church or synagogue let's say, or find another one.
And, I mean, Judaism is a religion
more rooted in a common text and a common practice
than a common theology.
So you have, for example,
Aristotelians like Maimonides, you have the Kabbalah,
and it's all one religion.
So what I say to people is that,
commit yourself to the text,
commit to yourself to some ritual life
because the ritual life has symbolic depth
that reaches into the soul.
Now find your particular path,
now find your teacher and your community.
And that's what I recommend to anybody,
is get a basic sense of, you know, is it Catholic?
Is it Protestant?
Is it episcopalian?
Like what the deal is what you're comfortable with,
now go find the place that's hospitable to you,
find the teacher and find your fellowship.
Right?
I think a lot of people find their way into religious
institutions out of, you know, some kind of family legacy
or an attachment to, you know,
the cultural bells and whistles that go along with it.
There's certainly nothing wrong with that,
but there's a very surface level engagement
with the actual teachings and then an even broader gap
between understanding those teachings and practicing them
in your daily affairs.
Absolutely.
And there are people who show up at my synagogue
and they say, "my rabbi told me to come to you.
I told my rabbi my concern and he just said,
you gotta go to Finley."
He says, "I don't do what he does,
and by reputation, he does it well."
And I sometimes people come to me and they say,
"But what about Maimonides?
What about Maimonides?"
I said, look, I'm not the guy.
I mean, there's a rabbi down the street
who's all over Maimonides and Aristotle,
I'm just not that guy.
Or, "why don't you do more social justice work?"
I said, 'cause the other rabbis
is doing social justice work.
So, there is something of a free market,
and I think people need to go to the place
that fits their needs.
So I have this niche of spirituality, depth,
mysticism on one side, the virtue,
the Greek tradition on the other, the stoic tradition,
you know, just over my life.
I've just mastered many different traditions
and people who like this mix, they come to me.
If they don't like the mix, they go to somebody else,
which is.
How does stoicism play into your counseling?
Thank you.
So, a very big part of my teaching
has to do with a resilience or another way of saying,
dealing with resistance,
but when I studied the Stoics I realized,
that actually is a product of something deeper.
And this something deeper is realizing the logos.
So the logos is the most important idea of stoicism,
not resilience.
So the logos says, there's a fundamental order
to the universe, and therefore there's a fundamental order
to human consciousness and therefore to the moral life.
And if you don't live according to the logos,
that's when you suffer.
So stoicism is, I will live according to the logos,
no matter what.
That's what the resilience is.
There's a proper way to order my life,
and nothing's gonna throw me off how to order my life
'cause I'm ordering my life according to the order
of the universe.
Mm-hmm.
So, the idea of the logos clearly comes into Christianity
in the gospel of John,
but the idea of that there's a mind of God
emanated into our realm, I mean, that you have that in,
I think throughout Greek philosophy,
you have been in Judaism, Christianity, Islam.
So, all of them have idea of the logos.
So the most important thing for me in studying stoicism
was not the resilience
because that kind of came natural to me.
You know, I mean, there so many Marine Corps legends.
We hold the line, they will not get any further,
or I'm gonna die trying.
That was the mythos into which I was inducted.
But the idea that there was a rational ordering
to the universe, and that if you don't align yourself
with it, you'll suffer unnecessarily,
that was something that I found really, really profound.
That is interesting.
I mean, I've spent quite a bit of time with Ryan Holiday
and I've read all his books, and I have read
a fair amount of stoicism,
but I'm not super familiar with that idea of logos.
And when you were talking about it,
I was drawing a comparison between stoicism
as a philosophy and how that differentiates from religion.
But on some level, there's a buy-in with respect
to the logos, right?
In that you have to believe that there is an order
of universe and that there are these natural laws
that are at play that require adherence on your part-
Precisely.
Or suffering, right?
So, on some level, there is a religious flair to that-
Absolutely, yes.
Philosophical traditions.
Very well put.
And that's why there are books on the stoic element
and rabbinic Judaism, because rabbinic Judaism, for example,
is mainly propelled by the idea of a mitzvah, a commandment,
whether you feel like it or not.
So I'll give you an example.
There are some Fridays when my wife and I are just exhausted
from a tough week, but it's Friday.
So we have to dress up.
Mm-hmm.
My wife pick flowers, we've gotta set the table.
We don't feel like it, but Shabbat is a mitzvah.
So despite what we feel,
we have to welcome the Sabbath bride into our home,
which means we set the table,
we put out the hall of the loaves, we set out the candles,
my wife picks flowers from the garden,
and we create a little garden of Eden
around her dining room table.
And, you know, our daughters grew up with it,
it doesn't matter what else is going on.
You gotta do the deal no matter what.
You gotta do the deal, exactly.
The mitzvah is more important than your feelings.
So this idea, it doesn't matter what I feel.
Now, look, we're not Orthodox,
but the idea is, when Friday night comes,
I don't have a choice.
I will snap my feelings around my duty.
So that idea... So, in the idea of mitzvah,
a wholly urging from God,
to which in general you can't say no in general,
is a very stoic idea.
It's your duty, it has to be done.
But it's behavior-based.
Absolutely.
Right.
And this is where they, you know,
I'm sure you're familiar the idea of the outside in,
first you do your duty, and then it sinks in.
Right.
'Cause then when you do sit at the table,
and you sing the songs and you smell the flowers
and we look at each other and, you know,
whenever we light the candles,
I think of the first from Proverbs,
"The light of God is the human soul."
And then I look at my wife and kids,
whoever's at our table and all of a sudden I'm in.
But you see had I not just said,
it's a duty that dragged me to the table
and put the candles out,
candles are lit, light of God is the human soul,
consciousness changes.
You know what I call that?
What's that?
Mood follows action.
Mood follows action, exactly.
Yeah, which is something I learned in early sobriety.
There you go.
So that's for me, a stoic duty snaps you into the logos.
And now I'm not a Orthodox stoic philosopher.
So for me, part of the logo says, love, justice,
truth and beauty and a beauty is a very big part of it.
So one thing that, you know, for example,
in the Jewish observance of the Sabbath,
a big part of it is beauty.
It's an interesting thing.
If you don't make your table beautiful,
you have observed the Sabbath.
So we have an obligation to create beauty.
I love that.
Isn't it?
Yeah.
Yeah. So, it's a duty.
Because beauty is one of the garments of God.
So how can experience God if you don't cultivate beauty
in your life?
Mm-hmm.
That's something I teach a lot, by the way.
To that person as a spiritual seeker, I said,
what's your connection with beauty?
They say, "what does that matter?
I want truth."
I say, beauty is a garment of God,
just as much as love, justice, truth and beauty.
So you have to cultivate a connection with beauty.
They say, "what do you recommend?"
Sergeant peppers (Mordecai laughing)
Right, right, right.
Start with what they're already-
Start with what they know, yeah.
Right.
As imperfect beings, we are all as humans,
a big part of this, I know you've spoken about,
this is the idea of essentially the daily inventory, right?
Beginning your day with an objective assessment
of how you lived your life in the prior 24.
What does that look like in practice for you?
So in my practice,
I actually call this the wisdom practice,
which is I'm sitting typically on my mat outside
in the morning, I go to my observer mind,
I looked down at my ego self,
and I just run through ego, anger at others,
anger at myself, resentment, despair, unresolved grief,
envy, guilt, shame, just, I run across the, you know,
what I'll call the dirty dozen, you know, whatever they are.
And when I discover one, it's as if it perks up.
Says, yeah, I'm active today.
So then I wanna go in and find out.
So for example, this is something I teach.
Anger almost always means a frustrated need, expectation,
entitlement or demand.
Right?
The NEED acronym.
Yeah.
That's the NEED acronym.
Everybody who studies with me has to know
this chapter and verse.
Okay. So if I'm upset with somebody,
it's not what they did, is they disappointed my need.
So I wanna stop being mesmerized by their deeds,
and focus on my needs.
All right, now, here's what happens,
when you focus on your needs,
your anger goes down 90%.
Mm-hmm.
'Cause you're not transfixed by somebody else's behavior.
So people say, "well, what about what they did?"
I say, we'll get through them later.
But is this not all rooted two things?
First, is this not all rooted
in expectations around outcomes?
Sure. Absolutely.
There's that.
And are not these, all these emotions
really all rooted in fear?
Like fear is the antecedent emotion
from which all of these other sort of-
Yeah, I'm not convinced of that.
Sometimes it's domination.
Mm-hmm.
And sometimes aggressive dominant people
are not motivated by fear.
They're just motivated by domination.
And when they don't get through-
What does that urge towards domination come from?
Does it...It's this idea that,
if somebody else gets that I can't, then.
You know I think that in the so-called Alpha Being,
they're not motivated by fear.
They really ultimately want domination
and extinguish anybody who stands in their way.
It's a type of person.
Now another person says, please stop.
That's fear.
The person says, "how dare you disobey me?"
They're not motivated by fear.
I think aggression and domination
are pretty pure as emotions.
I could be wrong.
Mm-hmm.
But I don't think fear is an antecedent emotion.
I think aggression and dominance over others is primary.
I could be wrong, but, you know, there are times,
I suppose I find myself upset.
You know, like, let's say I've asked my kids to do something
like super clear, rational, and they just don't do it.
And I feel angry.
Like, I asked you to do something clear, rational,
I was, you know, when,
and they just decided not to.
So I see the anger.
There's no fear there.
I just don't like being disobeyed.
Mm-hmm.
But I don't wanna be an angry guy.
Okay. So I have a need expectation
time and demand that my child chose not to perform.
Now I have to look and so my path is, was my need moral,
rational, and useful?
And when it goes to moral, rational, and useful,
from a rational perspective,
that's part of the dance with parents and children,
is children etching out independence by disobedience.
It's not personal.
It's part of healthy ego development of a child.
So if I respond with anger, I'm stunting their growth.
I'm not helping anybody.
So I calmed myself down.
I said, okay, say, can I talk to you a minute?
Sure.
I said, so I asked you to do this.
"Yeah, dad, I'm sorry."
It's not about sorry now,
'cause I have my coach hat and I have my authority hat.
This is the coach hat.
I want you to look inside yourself
and I want you to find the meaning of the disobedience.
See, I found the meaning of my anger,
but I'm getting rid of it.
Because what it replaces the anger
is my calling as a parent,
which is the parental soul of my child.
So now I'm calm and I say, okay,
this is actually a soul moment.
So my child says, "okay, I'm sorry."
I said, sorry is for next, right now I want you to ask,
why that was meaningful to you to disobey me.
They say, "I don't know."
I say, I have time.
(Rich laughing)
I'm just imagining how this would play out with my kids.
Try it.
They'd be like,
leave me alone.
Like I don't know.
No, try now.
I've been doing it ever since they were seven or eight years
old and they do something and you say,
what happened in your inner life
where that decision made sense?
Mm-hmm.
They say, "I don't know."
I say, I know you don't know.
And that's what it means to be a child in this family.
Mm-hmm.
Because your answer is, let me think or I'll look it up.
That's something you're all trained.
Mm-hmm.
You can say, let me think or I'll look it up,
after you say I don't know.
I know that you made this commitment with your kids
that you were never gonna be angry, right?
And you put something on one of their doors saying,
this is like a dad angry free zone or something like that?
Yeah.
(both laughing)
Which I loved because it's really, you know,
it's a challenge to the self, right?
When you feel that impulse.
And it made me think about all of these buttons
that we have installed that are the result
of the experiences that we've had,
or the traumas that we've survived,
wherein when they get pushed, you know,
logic goes out the window and we just impulsively react.
And it's only in the aftermath that we can reassess
or feel guilt or shame, or try to repair whatever damage
is done, but the trick is like,
how do you uninstall those buttons or, you know, kind of,
untrigger them?
Well, first of all is the virtue practice,
which is as I call, the Four Cs.
I started with, I will not anger under any circumstances,
under any provocation.
Fine print, I will not criticize people,
I will not complain to people about their behavior,
I will not condemn other people,
I will not engage in escalating conflict.
Now I fail.
But if I fail to my standard, I don't have an excuse.
I just failed.
Now, I set that every day.
I mean, when I wake up,
I will not anger and I will not be defensive.
I will not criticize, complain, condemn,
or engage in escalating conflict.
Someone's upset with me, after a couple of tries,
I'm not gonna engage what I called the bad JEDDI,
justifying, explain, I have all these acronyms, okay?
Bad JEDDI, I've never heard that one.
Oh yeah, the bad... I will not justify to an angry person
after I try to explain my point of view
'cause oftentimes-
I'm sorry, but.
Never, oh my goodness.
Someone says that to me,
all of a sudden I'm like doom squad.
I will hunt them down.
I say to people, if you're gonna study with me,
you never say I'm sorry, but.
An apology is an apology.
And by the way, that's a big thing for some people.
They've actually never heard the gold standard apology.
Okay?
So anyway, so, I will not justify explain, defend, deny,
try to give information to a hostile person.
So those are my, that's my virtue practice
under any conditions whatsoever.
If I find myself upset, I say, okay, I've already committed,
I'm not gonna do it.
Now my emotions are not obeying me.
So what I call the wall of virtue steps between my emotions
and my speech and behavior, I call this the wall of virtue.
So I set up a wall of virtue that says, I can have anger,
I can feel anger, I will not speak it,
I will not act on it.
Okay?
So I say it hits the wall of virtue,
bounces back into what I call a wisdom mill.
So I got all kinds of cool names for this stuff.
Okay?
So that I set myself up,
and I have people who I work with, whom I work.
They tell me about all the escalation and I say, okay,
wall of virtue time.
I do this at my... I have a Wednesday night wisdom class.
And it just began last week, wall of virtue.
For the regulars, it was a great review.
For newcomers it was the most stunning thing
they had ever heard.
(Rich laughing)
That when you get up in the morning,
you set up a wall of virtue and there are no exceptions
and if you fail, you apologize.
Mm-hmm.
And that's pretty stoked.
Yeah, that's a powerful practice.
I found that meditation and mindfulness go a long way
towards creating that buffer.
So, if you visualize it,
like you're inside of some kind of sphere
as you navigate the world and like what's gonna bounce off
and what you're gonna let in, how porous is that membrane,
mindfulness or a strict meditation practice
just buys me that little moment of self reflection
before I act.
And oftentimes that's the difference between,
doing something you're gonna regret,
or aligning your actions with your.
Exactly.
So that reflection practice
is what I call my wisdom practice.
But the wisdom practice taught me to do the virtue practice
when I wake up, because what people say is,
I know I shouldn't have done it,
my emotions got the better of me.
I say, so where you reflection creates a wall of virtue,
and this is actually mind training the brain.
Because what happens is there's a stimulus and a response.
So I train people.
What was the stimulus?
My child disobeyed me.
Response, anger.
I say, no, I want you to try this.
My child angers me, wall of virtue.
Train, and its like martial arts.
You know, like at the beginner in jujitsu,
someone gets on top of you, what do you want?
You wanna push them off?
What does that mean?
Arm lock.
The instinct to push somebody off of you
is inviting an arm lock.
So whatever you're gonna do in jujitsu,
do not push someone on top of you 'cause you're saying,
please arm lock me.
What would I do instead?
I say, first you're not gonna do that, right?
What do you do instead?
I say, okay, you hide your elbows in your hands
and you move your hips.
White belt the next week.
I keep forgetting because you're a white belt.
Right.
So when you feel the instinct to push your arms up,
instead, you hide your hands and arms and turn on your hips.
And it takes six minutes.
So it's called an intervention.
When I get the stimulus, okay, he's down now,
I don't have somebody on top of me, right?
I have let's say the disobedience of a child.
I've trained myself that my response is gonna be,
wall of virtue.
Which is like hiding my hands and turning on my hips.
Yeah.
It takes training.
So how do you train?
I say, you wake up in the morning and you train.
Yeah, you do the thing.
You train let's say, wall of virtue.
No anger, no Four Cs, no bad JEDDI, train, train, train,
and one day, your kid's gonna say something
you're gonna go, wall of virtue.
Mm.
But, good. JEDDI training is the path, right?
I often think what would a JEDDI do in this situation?
JEDDI never reacts.
Yeah.
Never loses their shit.
Yeah and JEDDIs can have fun, they can joke
and they're spontaneous, but the minute things go wrong,
the JEDDI says, oh, oh, we're in that space now?
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
There's an adult in the room.
Okay?
I'm gonna hold down the moral center.
So the kid does something you'd say,
oh, so you've changed the game?
You're doing the disobedience game?
Okay, I have a response to that.
Yeah.
But I'm not going to give myself a moral arm lock.
Right.
'Cause pushing is like arm lock me.
That's a white belt thing.
Right.
So you want to go up in the belts?
When someone does something to anger you,
wall of virtue kicks in.
Well, what you resist persists, right?
In that way.
Because if you're in that context,
you're allowing your child to do what they're doing,
you're not pushing your arm out to use the jujitsu analogy,
you're kind of, you know,
adjusting in a counterintuitive way,
but the pushing back is what then amplifies.
Exactly.
So ideally, if my child does something,
like my kids and my youngest is now 24,
but still, it can happen.
And typically if she does and she'll probably listen
to this, if she does something that I don't like,
I'll probably say,
"yes, that's not working for me right now
so I'll talk to you later."
Uh-uh.
And she'll say the same thing with me.
She'll say, "dad, it's not working for me."
And we disengage.
Right.
And then we'll talk about it later.
So the thing is, you train yourself.
When I feel anger, I go to the wall of virtue
and then I have a script waiting for me which is,
it's not working for me right now.
Can we talk later?
Now that's like training.
That's what a good blue belt can do.
All right.
You don't do what you feel like doing,
you've learned a next behavior
and a purple belt it's become their habit.
They don't even have the instinct to make a wrong move
because they've ingested the game.
Yeah, the training has been ingrained.
Yeah. So you know this.
How often does a jujitsu find its way
into your rabbinical sermon?
Like I would imagine this is a constant-
Within minutes.
(Rich laughing)
It's a game with my congregation.
They have like a betting floor,
when's the rabbi gonna mention jujitsu-
30 seconds until he drops the-
Exactly.
Right.
They never get to the betting floor but it's almost that.
Okay, Rabbi, we were just waiting until you mention jujitsu.
One of the amazing things about you is that,
you not only got into jujitsu and became a black belt,
you didn't start you jujitsu until you were like 45.
45, yeah.
Is that correct?
Yeah, yeah.
I was one of those karate guys and then I saw
the Gracies at the UFC.
Uh-uh.
And I said, okay, I'm doing the wrong martial art.
Wow.
And that brought you into it?
Yeah.
And you committed.
I mean, how long did it take you to get a black belt?
15 Years.
Wow.
Listen, I went through a heart attack
and a herniated disc.
Mm-hmm.
And I was the longest blue belt ever.
I think you...Three years for getting a blue belt?
I got my blue belt in three years, 2000, 2003,
then the heart attack in 06, which really sent me back
and a herniated disc in 08.
And so when you have a herniated disc
you have to learn everything again, because your back-
Did you have surgery or how do you rectify that?
Yeah.
But I stayed in.
And you're still at it?
Still at it.
Yeah?
How often do you train?
Four times a week.
Wow, wow.
Yeah.
And so what are some of the other lessons
that you've learned through martial arts
that find their way into-
I'd say jujitsu in particular is,
the way out is not where the pressure is.
So for example, if someone has mounted me, you know,
straddled me, and they're pressing down on my neck,
their hips are light, by definition.
They can't be equally heavy on their hips and their chest.
So I feel a chest pressure, I know their hips are light.
Okay?
If their hips are heavy, I got space on my chest.
And so what you learned to do is you kind of feel
where the other person is, don't get flustered,
the big thing is, the higher the belt,
the more calm you stay.
It doesn't matter what their pressure is.
And you start to detect where the way out is,
but you don't respond to pressure.
When there's pressure you figure out where the escape is.
So that's one of the main things is,
stay calm under pressure,
and slow them down, you know, hooks and angles,
so you gotta slow their progress down,
and then from training
you know where the escape is gonna be.
So if somebody hasn't made the choke, right, sorry.
Right.
If somebody has made a choke,
I can tell by their choke what my escape is gonna be.
So first of all I don't get flustered,
I just know that if someone's choking you,
they're both putting a move on and they're also giving
something up, by definition.
And extrapolating on that,
where's the wisdom that's applicable in other areas of life?
Okay, so, for example, the spouse is pressing on you.
So I get this.
Where the spouse is angry and pressing on you,
they wanna throw their arms out, stop, stop!
And so the idea is distract.
Say, could you repeat that?
What?
No. That what you just said, that was really important.
I don't know what I just said.
We'll try to remember, honey.
And all of a sudden their ego self is just spinning
because someone just said, can you repeat it?
So when you ask one to repeat something,
they got their eyes go up into the archive,
and their anger plummets 90%, it's a move.
So there are many scripts for deescalation.
So fear does not help.
So I say to people, are they gonna hit you?
No.
If they're gonna hit you,
we're having a different conversation.
Right. Okay, so your body's gone into fear
because of their aggression, yes.
And you know you're not gonna hit, right?
Get it, yes.
Okay, I'm gonna teach you some scripts
that are similar to jujitsu moves.
And so there are scripts you can use
with a brain of an angry person that almost invaluable.
That lead to deescalation through distraction.
Yeah, in boxing we call it deflection.
Like I don't wanna hit somebody,
but I know how to bob and weave and deflect.
So when people say, well, they said this,
I say, and so I said this, I saw you hit him back.
I said, don't do that.
Yeah.
Just deflect.
Bob, weave, through deescalation techniques.
So sometimes I actually train a person
in five deescalation techniques.
So the thing is, I'm being threatened,
I have to be defensive.
I get scared.
All right. First thing is jujitsu, calm down.
Mm-hmm.
Just calm down.
Where you gotta go back to the wall of virtue.
There you go.
Right.
That's it.
If you don't have that then you're just gonna, you know,
succumb to your base-
Exactly.
So one wall of virtue is for the angry person
and the other one is for the defensive person is,
you feel fear, go to your wall of virtue.
I'm physically safe.
Don't let this thing escalate.
Therefore, if you feel fear from a person
who's not gonna hurt you, your job is to deescalate
not to defend yourself.
They're two different things.
So the white belt wants to defend,
the higher belt wants to deescalate.
And it's a learnable skill.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
So there was an example where,
what your white belt self wants to do
is not what the higher belt self knows
is the right thing to do.
And how do you do it?
Train, train, train, train.
Are you the only rabbi that has a black belt in jujitsu?
So far.
Yeah.
(both laughing)
No one else has come forth yet?
And once they get it, they're coming for me.
I know that-
All you rabbis listening out there,
the challenge has been placed.
You know, when I got my black belt, man,
I was a hunted person.
Yeah.
(Rabbi laughing)
That's the nature of the game.
Everybody wants to snag the first black belt, so.
Right.
It's a really cool thing.
I love it, man.
I really, you know, I go in there and...
Like guys are very respectful.
Like they know I'm 66 and, you know,
I have bad shoulders and a bad back and-
But you're grappling with younger dudes.
I would imagine-
Big young guys and,
they're respectful but, they're there to train.
So I can't say, Hey, be nice to the old guy.
I just say, just be careful with the old.
Right, right.
But they're there to train and I gotta respect that.
So, I need to be a good training partner.
I needed, you know, we're sparring.
Right.
Right, right, right.
For people that come in for your counseling,
I would imagine a lot of couples or people that are divorced
or on the precipice of getting divorced.
What are the kinds of things that you're commonly seeing?
Escalating arguments.
Sometimes taught in therapy to talk
about their feelings,
which is one of the worst things you can do
when, you know, things are rocky.
So they say, "well, I told my spouse how I felt."
I said, don't do that.
In the beginning don't talk about your feelings.
"So what do I talk about?"
I say, what exactly do you want them to do or not do
in one sentence with a clean motivation and a clear goal?
"Well, I don't want them to get," so I said,
what exactly do you want them to do now
with a clean motivation and a clear goal that is observable?
And people are just so perplexed.
The idea of, it's not about my feelings
what would you like them to do?
So one person says, "well, I would like my husband
to apologize."
I said, go ask them.
Say, honey, I'd like to apologize for what you said.
And look at him.
He said, "I don't have to apologize."
You just say no.
Say no. You don't have to go into a big story.
Just say, I choose to not apologize.
I look at, let's say the woman in this case of this couple,
I'll say, now you'll have to learn to take no for an answer.
It's a skill.
Take no for an answer.
I'd like you to apologize, I choose not to, okay.
But how can I take no for an answer?
Because anything you say next will escalate
and you'll be back where you started.
But is there not room for acknowledging
the feelings in the context of making that ask?
'Cause if you were to say,
listen, the reason I'm asking for this apology
is because when you did this, it made me feel unseen
or like if you could like get past the reactionary response
in the moment to what's behind it,
like I feel unappreciated or whatever the case may be-
After about a month, after about a month.
Because what will happen if you say, I feel unseen?
Oh, right.
I'm not appreciated, you're not appreciated.
I'm not appreciated.
So what you start with is minimal.
I'd like you to apologize.
I choose not to.
I can take no for an answer.
Wow, no one got their eyebrows cinched
and is incremental like jujitsu.
White belt, white belt, white belt,
put a Stripe on your white belt.
More moves, more move, more, put another S
tripe.
And eventually when your blue belt,
you can talk about your feelings.
Mm-hmm.
So what I've discovered is,
many people think they have higher belt skills,
but the minute they try to use those,
here's how I feel, I don't feel seen and appreciated,
things escalate.
So my job is deescalation.
I say, you will talk about your feelings
when you both know how to talk about your feelings,
and you both know how to listen to the feelings
of another person without getting defensive
and then wanting to pile on, which is very typical.
So, you've intuited something correct.
Many people don't like this.
They say, "I have to talk about my feelings."
I say, can you wait a month?
They say, "no, I can't wait a month."
I say, okay, so, I'm not the guy.
Hmm.
Because this is stoicism.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
What's the natural order of things?
When things are spiraling apart,
you don't get to say whatever you want.
You gotta be careful until you build up trust,
you build up a good rhythm for good communication,
and then learn how to introduce those things slowly.
Hmm.
So I'm a big believer in,
when things are careening out of control,
everybody talking minimum.
Hmm.
So what do you say to the person who comes to you and says,
"you wouldn't believe what my ex-husband, ex-wife did.
They're doing this, they're doing that and it's terrible,
and I don't get to see my kids,
and, you know, they're telling all these other people
all these lies," there's a whole story, right?
And there's an attachment to that story.
And there's a perverted kind of,
what's the word I'm looking for?
Kind of attachment to how that story is received
when told to friends, right?
There's an out...And you get affirmed like,
oh, it's so bad, and you're right and that person's wrong.
Like teasing that apart and trying to get to an objective
truth with that person-
Sure, so first thing I say,
well, how's that going for you?
Meaning having the story in your head and acting on it,
is it producing what you want?
Typically not.
That story, those thoughts is part of your ego self
of blame.
It's called the blame disruption.
I'm gonna tell a story and there's a hero,
and there's a nemesis.
I'm the hero, they're the nemesis.
I'm good, they're evil.
Now, let me tell you my story.
We're all typically the hero in our own version of events.
Exactly, we have to bust that up.
Yeah.
How do you bust it up?
I call it the police report.
I say, you were fighting on the front lawn, the cops arrive,
so you stand there and you stand there,
they take out the little notebook,
they can't put more than on one little page
Then ask what happened.
"Well, when I was coming home from work."
No, what happened?
"Well, when I was a child."
(Rich laughing)
Okay?
So, you get what happened.
So what I do for a person, I say,
what happened?
For a newcomer it takes them more than half an hour
to tell me what happened.
Because their brains are in the accusatory narrative part
of the brain, as opposed to the objective brain.
So notice ego self accusatory narrative, observer mind, shh,
objective mind, what exactly happened?
Now, when a person can tell me in a lean way
what exactly happened, half the job is done.
Because they've accessed a part of their brain
that is not the emotional accusatory brain,
which is the reporting brain.
Mm-hmm.
So I say, can you just give me like five sentence
of what exactly happened?
And they say, "okay, so, I did this."
And I say, okay, got it.
So what would you prefer that they do instead of that?
"Well, I think they can."
I said, that's okay.
So now we're out of accusation to an ask,
different part of the brain, different kind of virtue.
I say, now, what I'd like you is ask them.
"Are they're gonna say no?"
I say, that's okay, they can say no.
But instead of arguing, accusing, defaming,
just ask them for what you like them to do
and tell them you can take no for an answer.
Hmm.
And they're gonna say, no.
And you say, thank you for answering my question.
Now, their ego self, just learn something.
It's not a fight, is just an ask.
And they can take no for an answer.
Then why they keep saying no?
I said, it's incremental.
Start by your communications are low level,
simple ask, simple answer, take no today.
You do this, we'll get to more complex conversations.
And, and they say, "well, I don't believe it'll work."
I said, give it a month.
What you're doing so far, hasn't produced any good.
Yeah, but Rabbi Finley, you don't understand
the reason why that makes me so upset
when that person does that,
you can't appreciate until like, relate to you
the entire history behind it.
I say, go ahead.
So I can give you the police report,
but it's meaningless because you don't understand
the context.
So everybody gets their statutory 10 minutes to vent.
So people vent.
Thing is I've heard it all before.
So I'll say, so, may I share with you now
everything that each of you now said from this point on?
'Cause I know the whole conversation,
'cause everybody's the same.
They have the exact same conversations.
I've never...Once they get into this mode,
I know everything they're going to say.
I know it sounds maybe a bit dismissive, it's just true.
You know, defensive people and accusatory people
have the exact same conversations.
So they say, "oh, you need more background."
I say, I actually don't,
but if you need to give me more background,
I'm happy to do it, but I'd love to get to work.
And-
Our situation is unique.
I know you think you've heard it all before,
but you don't really understand.
Yeah, I say, okay, try me out.
And they tell me and I go, it's a little bit unique,
but not unique enough that I'm gonna change
what I'm gonna tell you.
Which has no anger, no Four Cs, police report,
ask, answered, get everything down to a minimum
to learn how to process.
I said, you tell me where this does not fit you guys.
'Cause this is approach of, virtue, calm down the ego self,
higher self regulating ego self,
what exactly do you want?
Ask for, take no for an answer and move forward.
So I have found that when, you know,
people are very attached to, this is unique,
I'm so angry, I say, won't get better
if you stay angry or defensive.
It's just not gonna get better.
It's as if, when did they go,
oh, what you're saying is, anger, defensiveness
won't help solve the problem.
Bingo.
"But what they're saying makes me angry."
I said, no, they're triggering the anger in you.
That's your trigger.
You disassemble your trigger, they cannot make you angry.
Yeah, you have control over that anger response.
They don't feel they do
'cause they feel someone made me angry.
So for a person to realize, they triggered your anger,
but the trigger assembly is in you.
Sure. And why are you giving that person that much power?
Precisely.
Right?
Yeah.
So when you get to that conversation,
now we can get some work done.
How long, with willing people,
how long does that typically take?
With willing people who are not,
I'm gonna say in the first session,
if they'll let me be in charge.
Wow.
If they'll let me be in charge,
I give them everybody their 10 minutes of-
How many people let you be in charge?
I'd say, you know, 60%.
'Cause I say, you came to me,
so I'm gonna fix this for you,
but you have to let me.
And how is what you do different
than what a traditional therapist would do?
'Cause it's not therapy, right?
It's not therapy.
Yeah.
It's wisdom coaching.
A typical therapist would ask, how do you feel?
And what feeling from the...What event in the past
is being activated by this current situation?
I'm not saying they're wrong.
Many people are traumatized and they're driven by ghosts
and demons, everybody has them.
This is not my specialty.
Now I may refer a person to a therapist and say,
you needed someone to excavate the ghosts, you know,
the demons in you.
But interpersonally, talk about your feeling
to another person usually escalates.
'Cause when you say, you make me feel unseen,
that is a kind of a criticism and complaint.
Mm-hmm.
Whether you know it or not.
So, talk about that with your therapist,
'cause you may have to really do some excavating of demons.
What I'm gonna teach you is how to make this thing better
if you will let me.
And so people say,
"yeah, I actually heard that no one can make you mad only."
I said, yeah, it's actually true, so.
'Cause everything I have,
they've already heard somewhere, right?
Uh-uh.
These are people who read.
Right.
So they say, "well, what are you doing different?"
I say, I train you.
I'm gonna give you things you have to do every day
and if you don't do them every day,
it's not gonna make any difference.
So the next thing that I ask you is,
will you give me 10 minutes a day to train at home?
Mm-hmm.
Because my method does not work without training.
If you're not gonna train, I'm not the guy.
And they can come to your Jewish dojo.
That's right.
You can put them through the paces.
Yeah, so I give people exercises.
Uh-uh. You should give out belts.
I do.
Oh, you do?
I mean, not real ones.
You should now, I mean, like have real ones.
You know, I sometimes say to somebody,
put a Stripe on your belt, that was incredible.
Like, "my spouse did this, this and this,
but you know I remembered rabbi
that some people have bad days
and don't take them so seriously
and kind of let them get it out and say,
I'll talk to you later."
I said, put a Stripe on your belt.
Uh-uh.
And when they ask to person, you got a blue belt today.
It's like a blue belt at the studio.
No, I don't deserve a blue belt.
No, no.
I said, no, you keep this up,
you're a honest wisdom, virtue blue belt.
Uh-huh.
Right.
Because it's skilled, I can see it.
It's like at the rehab center, sobriety is not about days,
it's about processing.
So when, you know, when there's a newbie in the room,
you can tell by the way they process that they're not using,
but they're not sober in the aspirational sense.
Mm-hmm.
And then they're there for a while,
and suddenly I've watched them process differently,
you know.
And then you starting to see like a human being has come
and the light is in their eyes and they show some wisdom.
I go out there, a blue belt.
Wow, whoa, that's a purple belt.
That's like, that's not too often.
Talk to me a little bit more about working
with addicts and alcoholics.
Like, what does that look like?
And how does that mesh with 12 step?
Well, I work at a fantastic place.
The founders are...He's actually my rabbinical assistant,
a guy named Yeshaia Blakeney and his parents and others.
They have doctorates in moral psychology.
He grew up in the 12 step world and has a counseling degree
from Antioch if I'm not mistaken.
So they created a place that's based on teaching people
how to process well in addition to the 12 steps.
So they brought me in to do this piece
that I'm sharing with you.
And they said, I said, look, I'm not a company man
on 12 steps.
Yes I did it, I know it, but I really do my thing.
They said, "that's why you're on the faculty."
So I have a group every Friday morning
and I teach these things.
I teach Wall of virtue, Four Cs, bad JEDDI,
higher self ego self, I mean,
everyday I come in with a skill and I say,
can you recreate something that happened with a parent,
a spouse, a child that made you wanna relapse?
And can we process it through wisdom?
And so that's a typical session.
Is I'll present an idea and someone says,
"yeah, I want to process this.
And, you know, this made me so angry
and this made me depressed."
I said, okay, so let's process it with higher self
observing ego self, and doing an intervention,
coming out with something wise.
So, I mean, that's a barebone sketch of what I do
and what actually comes out in the room is sometimes quite-
But I would suspect there's a great receptivity though,
because anybody who's worked the steps specifically,
the Four step knows how to perform an inventory
and has engaged that muscle of trying to parse, you know,
what's my part in every situation that occurs?
Where can I find, you know, how I contributed to this,
you know, terrible outcome?
Where am I displaying fear, anger, resentment,
like it would lead to all of these sorts of things.
Yeah, so 12 steps really helps them in that.
So in many ways, there are already being propelled,
but I'll give you an example.
So, a guy borrowed the parent's car and it ran out of gas.
And so of course the parents, you're irresponsible,
all this insults and he flipped out.
I said, okay, let's just go deep inside.
What did you want your parents to do or not do?
"I didn't want them to criticize me.
I was in enough trouble already with a car out of gas."
I say, got it.
What's the likelihood that they are at this point
in their lives, they would know how not to blame
and accuse you when you did something they didn't like?
Where are they at in their moral development?
He said, "it would be impossible for them."
So your need, expectation and entitlement
was not connected to reality?
Mm-hmm.
Okay?
He says, "what do I do?"
I say, you feel incredibly sad.
Well, what do I say?
He said, "yeah, you're right.
I should have been more thoughtful."
Well, you're not responsible.
"I know I'm not responsible."
Well, what are you doing about it?
"I'm in recovery program."
Well, don't you think you should be responsible by now?
"Yeah, I should be but I'm working on it."
Just deflect, deflect, deflect, deflect, deflect.
They're gonna calm down.
And he said, "well."
And then afterwards you can say, hey, mom, dad,
can I have a minute of your time?
Sure.
"I want you to know I really felt horrible
when I ran out of gas, I know it's my old self
that doesn't plan ahead,
but I want you to tell me that when you guys piled on me,
it didn't feel good, and it didn't make it better for me."
"Well, what do you expect us to do?"
Right.
That's all I needed to say.
And then they come down to the center and we say,
don't do that anymore.
When your kid gets in trouble, you got a kid in trouble,
this is not the day that the parents pile on,
it's the day where the parents say,
"well, you probably feel bad enough already.
What can we do?"
Sure.
So this is a whole retraining of the parent brain.
But the JEDDI, from the perspective of the kid in recovery,
the JEDDI move is to not be ruffled
by whatever the parents say.
And I think there's value in mining that need even deeper.
It's not just, hey, you know,
I didn't want my parents to get mad at me.
Like there's a deeper need, which is likely, you know,
I've been a fuck up for a long time
and I screwed up a lot of stuff
and now I'm sober and I wanna be perceived as such.
And I can't get a break.
Like, no matter what I do,
it's never gonna be good enough
or they're never gonna see me, you know.
Yeah, you're 100% right on it, 100% right on it.
And that's where the conversation goes.
When are they gonna give me a break?
And I say, we're gonna have to work
with you and your JEDDI skill,
and then we're gonna work with the parents,
and you're gonna be able
to just sometimes say your little truth to the parents
and say, I really am in a program and I'm really working it.
And that I would love it if you guys would give me
a good word or a little bit of patient with me,
'cause what you want out of me is what I want out of me.
And sometimes the parent says, "wow, you're right.
You are doing what we want you to do
and we're not making it easy on you."
And, I mean, these are moments that are almost miraculous
when the kid comes back to me and says,
"you would not believe the conversation
I had with my father."
Right.
I was able to stay calm and say,
"Hey, dad, you're 100% right,
but I'm working the program."
And for the dad to say, "I really apologize."
It wasn't helpful, was it?
Yeah.
And the kid says, "wow, it's just like a new dawn."
Yeah. It seems like such a small thing,
but that's a really big deal.
Yeah. So managing that moment of anger and defensiveness,
centering yourself, the deescalating,
you're right, dad, you're right, mom,
that was irresponsible of me.
You're right.
Well, what are you doing about it?
"I'm in recovery."
Well, when are you gonna stop doing this?
"I hope soon."
Well, why aren't you doing it now?
(Rich laughing)
"'Cause I'm not there yet."
They go, "okay, all right."
(Rich laughing)
Yeah.
Right.
So you understand that when,
it's all the guys, when they learn this stuff,
it's like, wow, I can just be calm, JEDDI,
deflect, deflect, deescalate, and you come out of it.
Mm-hmm.
And then you start to go in with wisdom.
So it's really, I mean, the guys for whom this works,
they are so grateful and transformed by the things
that you and I were talking about here today.
It's hard though.
It takes a lot of work.
I mean, especially when you're newly sober and you no longer
can hide with your best friend,
and you don't have that coping mechanism.
You're just this live wire,
ready to pounce at anything and everything's on the surface.
And that's place where I teach recover integrity.
It's a warm community of people who can be vulnerable
with each other, they've learned how to talk and trust,
it's an excellent faculty.
So, this is where the friend they would talk to,
they're all working in the program.
Right.
And the faculty we're all of one mind.
I mean, we have all different approaches,
but, I mean, I really believe in this, you know,
when I look at the transformation that I have seen,
I'm one part of the thing.
And I think I have an important part.
But people get better.
Mm-hmm.
And it's an-
It's beautiful to witness that.
And over many years I've seen that unfold
in lots of different people and it just,
there's nothing more encouraging or heartwarming
than seeing that light go on in somebody else
and then over time watching their life not just change,
but flourish?
Mm-hmm.
It's truly miraculous.
It really is.
And so this is a quasi religion,
which means you have a community, you have a text,
you have rituals, you have a teaching,
you have novices moving up through the program, so-
You got a book too.
You got a book.
Yeah.
You got a Bible.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah, so, I get it, I get it.
Yeah.
I admire it greatly.
Mm-hmm.
And what I add to it is, the outsider, you know,
virtue, rationality, wisdom, depth,
so I have my own take on each of the 12 steps.
So I said, we're gonna talk about this step today,
but I'm gonna give you my take on it.
So it's-
Right, that's cool.
Yeah, I learned a lot.
I wouldn't be doing this if every time I taught
some part of my soul wasn't opened up.
Yeah.
I mean, it's transformative working with people
who are doing the work.
Yeah. Beautiful.
Yeah.
I want to shift gears a little bit here.
Sure.
I want to spend a few minutes talking about Kabbalah.
Okay.
Can we do that?
Absolutely.
I'm fascinated by this probably in large part,
because I know very little about it.
Okay.
Other than that at some point
there was a cultural inflection point
that involved Madonna and a lot of people wearing
red strings on their wrists?
Yeah.
And I know it's a journey into mysticism on some level
and also, you know, steeped in Jewish tradition,
but help me understand this by unpacking it a little bit.
Okay.
So I want to share with you a clip
that a friend of mine said and I borrowed,
he taught a course called Kabbalah no-red-strings-attached.
Uh-huh (laughing)
So that's my approach.
Yeah.
Kabbalah no-red-strings-attached.
Right.
Okay.
You're not allowed to walk around in the world
and advertise that you're a.
And they have no ethicacy.
If you're into the-
What is that about?
It's an amulet.
So I'm not in the amulet, Kabbalah.
There is a big part, a couple of which is the amulets.
It's a very big thing in the middle east.
I'm not into amulets.
You know, little hamsa signs and, you know,
things you put on your bed, around your neck, around your,
I just, I'm not in that world.
Uh-huh.
So, I'm more in the hard work Kabbalah.
Like it's a way to do the work, not the magical Kabbalah,
which is, put a red string to protect yourself.
All right. So I say, okay, fine.
If it works, I don't know if it works,
but if it works great, but that's not what I do.
So let me try to give you the basic understanding.
For anybody who wants to understand Kabbalah,
they have to understand Plato and Platonism.
With the idea that there are these ideal forms,
let's take the example of justice.
And let's say there's something called justice in the mind
of the infinite, and it percolates down through lenses.
And then it gets to a human being.
And for them, justice is whatever I want.
Like a little conceit, that's not fair,
meaning I didn't get what I wanted.
That's a pretty low level.
And then justice is, what if the law says.
Or justice is, whatever benefits my group.
And so there's higher and higher ideation
of what justice and fairness is.
You ask your average person,
they actually can't go very high up the ladder of mediation
'cause they're just not trained.
Mm-hmm.
But try to imagine that, I have a doctorate
in Social-Ethics so I'm steeped in moral philosophy.
So I know how to climb that ladder
and people find it exhilarating.
So try to imagine there's the mind of the infinite
that emanates a metaphysical concept down the ladder,
through the prisons, through the lenses,
until it gets to human consciousness.
Most people start out at a very low level of consciousness,
but they can climb up.
It's called the chain of being.
Mm-hmm.
The Kabbalah is rooted in a similar idea
called the emanations.
So if you type in your browser,
the emanations of the Kabbalah, they're called the sefirot,
S-E-F-I-R-O-T.
Type that in, you're gonna see these 10 emanations,
that is the Kabbalah.
If you have those 10 emanations it's Kabbalah,
if you don't have it, is not Kabbalah.
So the first thing about Kabbalah is an eminent Tory system
from the infinite mind of God
that emanates these powers, these values,
as it were into the consciousness of the human beings.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, that's the first step.
Okay?
So the next step should be pretty obvious is,
if we are created in God's image,
then just as this happens in the divine is happening in us.
So everybody has their own copy of the 10 emanations,
and so my job is to work my 10 emanations.
I'll just add one more step.
There's a kabbalistic teaching that,
as some of these emanations are cracked, broken, and flawed,
as they get into the human being.
So what is my life's work?
To repair my emanations.
It's a way of ordering the inner life.
Now, I'm talking about the spiritual psychology
of the Kabbalah, not the,
I mean, not the 100 hours of teaching I could give
if I were teaching more academically,
but I think you're asking what's the practical usage?
Mm-hmm.
It's a way to understand the mind of God,
and human consciousness in these 10 eminent Tory systems.
Hmm. In other words,
finding a way to tether the flawed human consciousness,
and relate it in some way to the infinite.
Yes.
Very well put.
From a spiritual, psychological perspective for example,
one of the emanations is called (foreign language)
which means love, beneficence, loving kindness.
So let's say I have a emanation in me that is love mind,
but then I look and I realize, some of my acts of love
are actually after reciprocity.
Sometimes I'm trying to be super accommodating,
sometimes I'm trying to manipulate some of you
by being a nice guy.
Mm-hmm.
That's lower level stuff.
So that's crapped.
Another one is called (foreign language)
which has to do with judgment and rationality.
Lowest level is prejudgment or prejudice.
Yeah, I have a judgment, but it's all messed up.
Produces hatred.
So notice in each one of these emanations, for example,
love on one side, judgment on the other,
this is Finley's teaching.
They have higher and lower manifestation.
Right, I got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So each one of these, now this is my adapter-
There's an ideal, and then there's the human manifestation
of that at various levels.
Correct.
So, I have to have a theory of,
what is the ideal idea of love?
So if people ask me I say, well, it has to do with service,
truly benefiting another person,
which is not what I think they want.
And maybe even not what they think they want.
Mm-hmm.
It's complex and that's another
part of my spiritual psychology is,
the willingness to think complexly,
because most people want to simplify,
I say, as simple as possible, but don't avoid complexity.
So thinking about love, thinking about rationality,
about justice, so these are two,
they merge into one called truth and beauty.
So, deep meditation on truth.
What do we mean by truth?
Was maybe a true human being, was mean to know the truth.
What is beauty?
These are deep conversations.
Mm-hmm.
So try to imagine, I'm talking of the lower seven now,
these are the non mystical ones,
studying the lower seven is exhilarating.
It's a curriculum to think about the deepest things
of human consciousness in orderly way
with other people who know the terms.
So for me, the Kabbala is a way to study human consciousness
in a relatively contained system
with other people who know the jargon.
Mm-hmm.
So it's exhilarating.
It's also transformational.
Meaning as I study them, is ways of self understanding
and a standard for growth.
Mm-hmm.
So, eminent Tory system
that has a spiritual psychological dimension
that in some ways sets out a curriculum
for lifetime inner work.
Yeah, that's cool.
So in the context of love, for example,
there's divine love,
the sun doesn't choose upon which it's going to shine on,
it shines, you know, equanimously on everything
versus transactional love or a relationship that's really
a social contract and all the various permutations
in between on this escalating scale
towards a more divine expression.
Yeah, well, I got paid, love your neighbor as yourself.
Right.
Yeah, so, the more you know about the word
in as many languages you know,
and then including philosophy, psychology,
different kinds of psychology.
So whenever, let's say I'm gonna study
that (foreign language)
I invite people, bring in everything you know.
Mm-hmm.
And let's create a theory that seems about right,
and then let's assess ourselves.
So if I say, I love my wife, I love my children,
does that mean, for many people, now that I love you,
here's what you must do.
Right.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Conditional love.
Yeah.
Which most relationships on some level are a function of.
Yeah, but even we say-
We love, you know,
so-and-so no matter what,
but they go off and they murder somebody or, you know.
Yeah, so that's-
You know, like you're out.
So, that's a metaphor.
Yeah.
That's not real.
But I'm even speaking with a person that says,
"now that I love somebody here are their duties."
Mm-hmm.
That actually happens.
So I said, no, how about if now that I love somebody,
here are my duties?
"Well, what about what they have to do?"
I say, we'll get there.
But that even gets more complicated because service
is self-serving in many ways.
Like I feel better when I'm in service.
So, how much of my pull to service
is motivated by my personal or selfish desire
to feel better versus being completely altruistic?
Yeah, but a consequence is not a motivation.
So if you know that when you serve somebody,
you know the consequences will be inner wellbeing,
that's not your motivation.
Mm-hmm.
You have to distinct between motivations and outcomes.
So the outcome of service is wellbeing,
but that's not my motivation.
My motivation is to serve other people.
Mm-hmm.
I'm not gonna question that.
So a person says, "well, what if I'm really only doing it
for the good feeling afterwards?"
I say, well, are you?
Sometimes.
Sometimes, okay.
Yeah.
So that's pretty good, sometimes.
That's like, yes, like a C.
But I think being honest about that is important
and that's, you know, in part based upon the way
you just described it, it feels like,
Kabbalah in certain respects is a path towards disabusing
humans of the delusions that we commonly harbor
about our actions and why we behave the way that we do.
It can be, I mean, in the way that I teach it.
So if we're gonna talk about love and service
and a person says,
"but I don't know if my motivations are clean."
I say, that's a great conversation to have.
And if that's the conversation that you need to have,
let's have it.
Mm-hmm.
How do you understand the depth of your own motivation?
If that's what's haunting, you let's have that conversation.
So are you the type that believes that all motivations
are narcissistic?
They go, "yeah, aren't they?"
I say, no, they're not.
You asking me?
No, some motivations are pure.
Sometimes we truly want to help other people.
And if you're asking me as the rabbi,
don't doubt that 'cause it's true.
Sometimes we are motivated to serve others.
Now, if you say, well, I don't know when.
I say, great, then that is what we're gonna do
with (foreign language)
So notice sometimes when I teach (foreign language)
the person will reveal to very quickly,
"here's what I need to study."
Yeah.
Same thing with (foreign language) boundary setting.
"But rabbi Finley, when I draw boundary
it makes other people feel bad.
Is it a righteous boundary?"
Yes, I said, so what are you feeling bad
have to do with it?
"I don't know, I just don't like to disappoint people."
I said, great, so now we know what to talk about.
Mm-hmm.
So, because I've been studying this forever, by the way,
not that I can-
But there's a narcissism in that,
and you harbor the power to make somebody else feel poorly.
There you go.
So, see you're right on it.
So if I were to study this with you,
you would bring a set of questions
to every single one of them that need to be addressed.
But these 10 emanations give us the curriculum of,
which questions?
Mm-hmm.
So if we're studying love,
we'll have one set of questions.
If we're studying justice and rationality and judgment,
why have a different set of questions.
So this is the beautiful thing about it,
is when we're studying the spiritual psychology
of the Kabbalah, we're studying this one today.
Now they all interconnect obviously.
But you see the two things you just brought up,
they're fabulous questions, but why would we have them?
Because I'm doing the spiritual psychology of the Kabbalah.
So, sometimes when I study with a person, they go,
"oh my God, that's like, what you do?"
I say, yes, it's what I do.
Yeah.
But I wanna wear the red bracelet so that everybody knows
what I'm up to.
Okay.
(Rich laughing)
Right.
You know, people gotta do what they gotta do, right?
I'm not judgemental though, that's all.
Your strain of this is called Lurianic, right?
Yeah.
So explain that a little bit.
Okay.
So Isaac Luria, so the Kabbalah develops
in the late 1100s, 1200s,
and Isaac Luria added a dimension that these emanations
that we're talking about, cracked and broke.
So he added the idea of the breaking of the vessels.
Okay?
Right.
So, it's as it were the mind of God
that we can apprehend shattered.
So, we therefore are each,
articulations of the shattered mind of God.
I know it's a strange theology.
So, how do we heal God?
By healing the shattered vessels within us.
Mm-hmm.
I like that.
Isn't it great?
It's beautiful.
I don't pray for God to heal me,
God wants me to heal God.
Mm-hmm.
How do I heal myself?
Repair my vessels.
That's how I heal God, that's how I heal you.
If you and I have a relationship
and we both know we come with shattered vessels,
let's help each other.
And in doing so, we heal God.
So as ultimately humanistic, because the focus is not on,
oh God, please, but rather,
God, you gave me a duty to repair the vessels,
I'll spend my life trying to repair my vessels
and help other people and the end of my life
I'll show you my work.
Well, there's a Zen Buddhism flare to that in that,
the path forward is really an internal journey
of becoming the most fully authentic version of yourself.
You nailed it.
So this is a path toward authenticity in our work,
moral growth guided by the system
of the spiritual psychologic kabbalah.
And when people say,
"oh, so I found something wrong with me."
I say, no, you found out the nature
of your shattered vessels.
And that's why on the character defect.
And what a beautiful epiphany
and a great place to begin this journey.
Yes, when I say to people, I say,
there's nothing wrong with you discovered your work.
I mean, that really relieves people.
And that's one reason when we do their character defect
in the 12th step.
I say, if I may, we don't have defects, we have work.
I know 12 step, you gotta do it, help me here,
we talking to Finley, I don't like that word.
What I like is, I've discovered the work I need to do.
Mm-hmm.
Which means you discovered your configuration
of the brokenness of God,
and now you're called upon to work on it.
It's nothing wrong with you.
You discovered your participation in the brokenness of God,
get to work.
Mm-hmm.
So for me, it takes away the shame of,
oh my God, this is wrong with me, I'm bad at this,
and, you know, I'm not an iron man.
And I say, it's okay, you just discovered your work.
That's okay.
Wow.
You just discovered your work.
Yeah. That's really cool
how that intersects with recovery.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
All you've done is discover your work,
there's nothing wrong with you.
Mm-hmm.
So for me to say, "guys, I'm such a fuck up."
I said, no, you're not.
You discovered your work.
You've been avoiding your work.
Yeah.
I get it.
Uh- huh.
But you discovered your work, let's get to work.
You avoided your work, the universe has been knocking,
start knocking a little bit louder-
God's saying-
Till Finley shows up.
Yeah, God is saying, please heal me.
No, I'd rather drink.
God says, "I really need you to heal me."
See, this is where like, I don't, I mean-
And it's such a flip.
Isn't it a flip?
How I've always thought about that, yeah.
So, I'm not saying, don't say, turn over to higher power,
but rather the higher power is saying, "please heal me."
Only you can do it.
Hmm.
Yeah, so, it's a-
There's a...In just pondering that,
there's like this infusion of agency, right?
You got it, man, you got it.
Now this is Finley's interpretation of Lurianic Kabbalah.
But for me, Lurianic Kabbalah produces a powerful degree,
exactly as you said of human agency.
God needs me to heal God.
It's up to me.
And we're gonna do this together.
And as we heal each other and heal God,
that actually makes the whole human condition better.
If enough of us are doing it.
So when people discover this, I mean, you know,
I have had people break down in tears when they heard,
there's nothing wrong with you,
you discovered your work.
Hmm.
Some I suspect would find it blasphemous though.
The idea of man healing God is outrageous.
(both laughing)
I've had people walk out of my synagogue when I said it.
Yeah.
I said, it's okay, go study with some other rabbi.
So I say to people, I'm in the spiritual psychological,
Neo lurianic, Neo capitalistic tradition,
it's this thing that I do.
Yeah.
I'm not telling anybody they have to do it,
I'm just telling people what I do.
Yeah.
If you like it, join in.
Right.
We gotta wind this down a couple of minutes,
but I do wanna ask you about one more thing, which is,
it's somewhat related to my Zen Buddhism comment,
which is that, you had Leonard Cohen in your-
He was a congregant, yeah.
And I know you tell an amazing story
about how you guys met, can you share that with us?
Well, I'll tell you what happened.
The person who produced Anthony is his woman,
wife, woman, blue alert,
it's a guy named Larry Klein.
Larry's a member of the congregation and Larry and Lucy
and they got married by me to their wedding.
Mm-hmm.
So Larry and Lucian ask me,
"what do you recommend for entertainment?
We don't want to do like the old thing."
I said, well, have a few cool people
talk about the wisdom of marriage.
They say, "okay, you."
All right?
So I was centered, seated next to Leonard,
I didn't know who he was, I heard the name, Leonard Cohen,
it didn't ring any bells or anything.
Yeah.
So then I got up to did my thing.
So I had this little shtick that I did,
10 contrarian commandments for good marriage.
So remember that, be happy, don't worry?
Yeah.
So I said, worry, 'cause it was actually
a Jewish spiritual practice, which is,
worry about if you're a virtuous person.
Not worry about outcomes, worry about yourself.
And then instead of being angry, be sad.
So I said, forget about, don't worry, be happy,
and then I explained, be sad and worry,
but I translated into Jewish, spiritual psychology.
Okay.
You want to be a good person?
Worry about yourself.
Don't get angry, be sad that you're not getting your way.
So I went through these 10 contrarian commandments
of a good marriage.
And I got a lot of laughs, a lot of depth,
and people lined up to talk to me,
like at the wedding reception,
and I sat down and later Cohen says,
"you know, that was really cool."
You know?
So he and Anthony really dug it.
Mm-hmm.
I go home and call my wife who was in Israel
and I said, hey, ever heard guy, Leonard Cohen?
She says,
"I used to cry at night listening to those albums", right?
And I say, I didn't know who he was, I'm sorry.
She says, "you sat next to Leonard Cohen?"
I say, I didn't know.
So he and Anthony walked into the synagogue
the next Sabbath.
And they just start coming to the synagogue
and attending all my classes,
and we four became good friends and he and I
became very connected and I was his rabbi.
Mm-hmm.
You know, I can say he was,
we weren't chummy because we felt a little bit awkward
around each other, unless we studied something.
So he really knew Kabbalah very well,
he clearly has the gift of a muse,
I got the inner life of his poetry.
So some time he'd come to me and say he says,
"Rabbi, you wanna hear a poem I've been working on?"
I just say, sure.
You guys, how long you been working on?
And he says, "15 years."
Yeah.
I said, how long"
He says, "120 verses."
I said, I got time.
I was like-
Uh-huh.
So, you know, and I would say,
my favorite song is bird on a wire.
He goes, "oh, you wanna hear the rest of the verses?"
So, I was like,
I mean, all of the songs have hundreds of verses, right?
So we had a great connection, you know,
I say he wasn't my friend-
Based on philosophy.
Philosophy and he wanted a teacher.
I knew what he wanted because of in the Buddhist world
where, you know, consciousness gets emptied out,
and, you know, meditation is a tuning fork to reality,
he wanted a guy that actually taught moral realism
and the world is real,
and there really is a divine interfacing with human beings.
And it was not what he believed,
but he liked being in a relationship with somebody,
with a rabbi, that did not tell him what he believed.
Right, to stress test his ideas.
And for me to stress test mine on him,
and he loved hearing what I had to say.
It was an interesting thing.
I think he wanted a rabbi who meant it,
in the deepest way imaginable
and he thrived on it and I thrived on him.
So, people ask me about his music, I say,
look, I'm not an expert on Leonard Cohen music.
And we were friends to a point I was his rabbi,
I don't have anything more to say.
Right.
And he characterized himself as more of a Zen Buddhist,
right?
Well, he said this, he said, Zen Buddhism
is not a religion, he said,
tuning forth for consciousness.
He says, "my religion is Judaism", right?
And he said, "and you're the best rabbi I ever met."
Beautiful.
So, I said, okay.
So I never asked him about Zen Buddhism.
He, you know, like, you don't say to Leonard Cohen,
where do you get the ideas for your songs?
And tell me about this Zen Buddhism?
He came to me to be his rabbi.
So I got to find out, what are you looking for?
And can I do it?
And what he was looking for, I could do.
And that was our relationship.
Wow.
So it was, people say, "what was it like?"
I say, I was his rabbi,
I don't know how you want me to explain this.
It's like, what I do to anybody who choose me the rabbi.
Right.
What are you after?
Can I do it?
All right, let's get to it.
What a cool experience.
It really was.
Yeah.
He was one of the man, just, you know,
one time I said to him, I said,
as I started really reading his poetry, I said,
you know, Leonard, I think most of your poetry is liturgy.
He says, "I thought all my poetry is liturgy."
Hmm. He wanted to know which parts weren't.
Yeah, like wait, like what are you saying?
You know?
And so then when I realized that he saw himself
as being in the line of king David.
The, you know, the Psalms?
Yeah.
And then all these great liturgist through the years,
people who wrote all this beautiful liturgy
of the Hebrew tradition?
He saw himself as in that chain of tradition.
He says, "I'm a liturgist.
I write poetry about God and for God,
and for people who want to sing to God."
Mm-hmm.
So, that was what alerted me to what's happening with him.
And, it was extraordinary.
It really was...I miss him terribly.
He was-
Yeah, he was a gift.
Something that, a kind of person to be around
and talk to, he was just, utterly unique.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah, he was nice 'cause he really loved my wife,
they had a very cool relationship.
Len and I were a little bit awkward with each other,
she got him, he's a ladies man.
Uh-huh.
And my wife got him quickly.
And he couldn't pull his thing on her.
Uh-huh.
(Rich laughing)
So it felt safe with him.
She says, yeah, Leonard, yeah, whatever.
You know, like, and so, he felt so safe with my wife.
They really had a beautiful relationship.
And then my wife became best friends with Anthony.
Mm-hmm.
You might not know this,
but I'm actually awkward socially, you know,
so between the three of them,
they had always loved going out, and I'm kinda like-
You're on the outside.
I was kinda like the guy watching this.
I'm the one who he came to!
No, no, no, no.
I don't have any of that.
I know I'm awkward.
I know I'm a socially awkward person,
and sometimes best thing for me is just to sit back
and watch the magic.
I'm not reading a lot of social awkwardness today.
I know. Because I'm on.
Yeah, yeah.
This is my happy place.
But, you know like, if we sat socially,
I'd run out of things to say.
I have a hard time believing that.
Okay.
But we do have to end this.
All right.
Final thing.
Right.
I think it would be good to just end this with a few,
thoughts for the person who's listening or watching
who is tiptoeing around the idea of what it means
to be a spiritual being, having a human experience,
is trying to, you know, reckon with finding
a little bit more meaning and purpose in their lives.
And doesn't have the vernacular or the experience
to really do this by themselves.
Like how do you?
Sure I love the metaphor?
Yeah.
It's a very available metaphor.
Spiritual being, having a human experience,
is that what you said?
Mm-hmm.
But to mean that takes a tremendous amount of work.
Because you have to go to your spiritual center,
and that is the most, and only real thing.
And getting to that spiritual center, you know,
to the place deep in the inner life,
where the love of God is flowing in through the fountain
and you're standing right there in the fountain.
You're at the deepest part of the soul.
And you come up out of that, and you have one urge,
which is to love other people.
And anything that gets in the way of that,
you gotta stop it.
And love life, and create beauty.
So, so many things come from rooting yourself
into the deepest part of what I will call,
the life of spirit, which for me as a religious person
is the interface between the, you know,
the mind of God and the mind of human being,
or the soul of the universe and the soul of the human being.
Now, when you get there, it's not as if you have meaning,
meaning has you.
This is one thing I really believe deeply.
We like to say, I have meaning in my purpose in life,
but if you really feel it,
it arrives at you and grabs you by the lapels,
and it owns you.
Mm-hmm.
So I don't have meaning, meaning has me.
I don't have purpose, purpose has me, it's claimed me.
You know, going back to the stoic sense.
So, when you feel claimed by love, justice, truth
and beauty, that propels you, now that we have claimed you,
here's what you must do.
So what happens is that, deepest sense of being claimed
by the divine, I'm speaking as a religious person,
when God claims you in the garments of love, justice, truth,
and beauty, and pushes you into life,
well, now you know how to be a human.
And what you have to do is,
you have to live interfacing in the world,
propelled by the meaning and purpose that has claimed you.
For me, in the modalities of love, justice, truth,
and beauty, but always go back to that deep experience
of the soul.
So it's a constant dialectic between, you know,
being present in the world and being present to the soul,
present to the world, being present to the soul.
So, the person who's hearing this and says,
"how do I do that?"
You know, I would say, think deep things, you know?
What is love?
What is beauty?
What is truth?
Just start taking your consciousness
and drilling through the block between the mind
and the soul, and drill down.
I remember it happening to me when I thought,
well, I have these holy words,
and knowing that they had soul residents,
and drilling down through that grated block
and when I hit the water, and the water just float up,
that's what I would tell people.
Yeah, that's beautiful.
I think there is a epidemic of people feeling a desire for,
but a lack of that animating force.
And I think, for those that lack it or are seeking it,
that was beautifully put, this idea of it claiming you,
but in order to put yourself in a position to be so claimed,
you have to commit to living an examined life
and understand that patience is going to be important
because it's not a light switch.
The examined life.
You have to examine the contents of consciousness
and go to the deepest place you can, do it every day.
And that, you'll hit the waters.
You'll hit the living waters of the soul.
Mm-hmm.
Just keep at it.
That's a good way to end it I think.
All right.
I think we landed this plane.
We landed the plane.
Yeah, how do you feel?
I feel great.
Okay.
That was terrific.
I loved it.
Let's do this again.
Absolutely man.
Can I come to your synagogue too?
Anything you want,
of course.
I'd like to hear you,
do your thing.
I would be so honored and this was really,
we did a significant thing here today.
You think so?
Absolutely.
I hope so. I hope it's helpful to people.
Yeah.
I loved it.
I loved every minute-
You were right in the zone too.
So it's really, it's an honor to be interviewed
by you truly.
Yeah, thank you.
If people want to connect with you,
what's the best place to-
Well, my synagogue or @torah.org.
My website, rabbifinley.com.
It's all very 90s clunky and, you know,
we're promising to upgrade it,
and one day have a room like this.
It's a wonderful studio you have,
and I got so much to do and so much to say,
but in the meantime,
I have my classes on Tuesday and Wednesday nights on Zoom,
a 45 minutes each-
Right.
My Shabbat evening, a 20 minute teaching on Friday night
and our teaching on Saturday morning, open to everybody.
Many people are not Jewish, because I don't teach Judaism,
I teach using Jewish symbols, metaphors and myths
as a way to get at truth.
Right.
So everybody's welcome,
and I think any person like you would love it.
Excellent.
I'm gonna check it out and I'll put all those links
in the show notes.
Yeah, thank you.
So everybody can figure it out and hopefully
send a few new people your way.
All right, all right.
Yeah, thanks so much.
All right, man, it's been a pleasure,
real pleasure, Thank you.
Peace, plants.